and another day another junior speed
chess championship match i'm grandmaster
robert hess alongside me
as per usual grandmaster daniel
naradiski dania
yesterday we had an absolute thriller of
a match between nihal tsar and anton
smirnov
today is going to get even better with
our matchup between sam sevion and
alexis serrano
it just might robert a pleasure to be
commentating with you
today and another amazing day of action
up ahead
these players and i i say this every day
and i really mean this every day
uh these players are incredible every
match
holds the potential to be just edge of
your seat entertainment and so far every
match has delivered and
robert knowing these players there's
absolutely no reason to believe that
this match also will not deliver
oh it certainly will and we have our
smarter chess match predictions which
are brought to us by chess goals
see it's a pretty even balance here the
favorite is sam sevien and that comes
in both the longest time control it says
four and a half three enough prediction
in his favor and the five plus one he
is expected to go down a game in the
three plus one but then win the bullet
by one so that's like
as back a fourth matchup as you could
ask for
they are very evenly matched as
indicated by their blitz and bullet
ratings
uh they both play a lot on chess.com uh
they're they're blitz and bullet
veterans
so there's going to be no sort of
experience gap there uh
and we'll definitely keep an eye on uh
the smarter chess predictions as the
match
uh goes along but first uh robert uh
very important tournament that's coming
up oh yeah and it's not it's kind of
tomorrow i'm losing track of the days
here but
tomorrow is the speed chess
super swiss fifteen thousand dollars in
prize money i'm sure there will be many
super grandmasters taking part
and it's for an opportunity to qualify
for the speed
chess championship so the players in
this field and the jscc as we
take a look at the overall bracket they
have an opportunity to qualify directly
the person
whose face and name goes underneath that
trophy down there
who wins this jsc bracket they will make
their way to the speed chess
championship
but other players will have a chance by
participating
in the super swiss this weekend and done
as we do look at this bracket
we see that with our final quarter-final
match-up sam savion and alexis serrano
if you're jeffrey zhang who would you
prefer to face
nobody i would prefer i would prefer to
be karpov when he faced fisher
uh i mean i think that he probably has a
preference on the basis of
who he faced more over the border who he
knows better i guess maybe he faced
sebby and more times over the board he
knows him a little bit better but
alexis serrano is is a household name at
this point he is
of course russian but he's played across
the globe
he's you know he played recently in st
louis so i'm sure jeffrey is familiar
with both of them
um and they have somewhat different
styles i think what makes this match
really interesting
uh is the fact that sevien and serrano i
i know them pretty well both of them and
they have
divergent sort of styles and approaches
to the game uh which we'll talk about
and i think that will produce some very
interesting chess
yeah for sure and they're both super
tough so when we
ask who would jeffrey rather play it's
kind of like oh who is
the weaker player actually i think as
far as our matchups go this is a
pretty good toss-up because if i'm
remembering correctly
sevien is around 2660 and serrano
around the same i actually don't know
who's the high rate the two in terms of
classical
feed a ratings but this is a tough
matchup no matter who goes on to the
semifinals and jeffrey he looked
great he has looked great so far in the
jscc
but his opponent going forward will also
be a great player and we do have liftoff
down yet
we do and as you said this match is
bound to be about form uh both of these
players
it really is a toss-up uh so a lot will
be determined in the early going here in
the five minute one thing to note
lexi serrano is famous in russia among
the juniors as an opening specialist he
has
incredible opening preparation he is a
specialist in using computers
uh to find novelties and i heard all of
this from sort of the top russian
commentator grandmaster sergey shipov
who
uh regularly sings serrano's phrases so
for sebby and robert it's going to be
very important to stick to what he knows
and uh to spend some time in the opening
not get into any trouble particularly
with the black pieces
as we see in english here in the first
game right and with the white pieces we
expect that
you know he he should be able to get a
slight pull that's what these
highly rated grandmasters usually do
when they have the first move advantage
and right now his knight and a4 looks a
bit awkward but it did drive this bishop
back to a passive square in e7
so that's the good news and that's why
cevi and i almost called him konovets
because i
know his username so well he drops his
knight back to c3 saying my job has
been done and white has more advanced
pawns
on the you know in the center over here
so what do you make of this dynamic and
how are the players going to
push forward from here yeah this is a
very
interesting position it has overtones of
a sort of old indian structure
uh which is of course kind of like the
king's indian where the bishop coast
goes to e7 i think by and large
sir surinaz has solved most of his
opening problems i i think one idea for
to go rookie a bishop f8 and uh to
retool his pieces that way
it's important not to take on e4 uh
prematurely because then
black exposes the weakness on d6 so
white does have the space advantage
sevien could deploy his other bishop to
b2 or to e3
and he decides instead to lock up the
center interesting and we see a lot of
tension
here in the center the winner of this
central tension
i think is going to be the one who gets
the clear advantage here
as they transition into the middle game
robert yes and it's important
that neither player has captured just
yet because
when you do capture something you want
to make certain that it benefits you in
some way
and look at this tension remain on the
c6 and d5 squares
and now it's all about the queen trade
do you take on b6 which
gives black double pawns but you are
capturing towards the center
or do you play bishop e3 so he does take
and he plays an e4 so he's playing for
central control yeah
daniel we know full well that anytime
you push this pawn to e4 the bishop on
g2
looks a lot less potent putting behind
amazing bishop
while you're having a problem with his
mission right here there's only a lot of
squares but yeah h4 bishop h3
uh this definitely does have these king
zindini kind of vibes
and it's very easy to just assume that
white is much better because he has a
lot more space i think white is better
um i think because white does a lot more
space
i don't think white's advantage is vast
and i think what sarna has to do
is finds some way to contest light's
authority in the center
um right i'm not loving though his own
bishop on h5 is kind of out of play
robert i mean f5
always opens up white's bishop not to
mention it's currently just not possible
because of e takes f5 rook takes f5 and
then g4 so
this is unpleasant stuff here for
serrano i'm with you you know i was
focusing on how e4
limits the scope of white's bishop on g2
but the
as you're mentioning the bishop on h5
which likely is going back to g6
doesn't look so great either and yes
black you play f6 and move the bishop
back somewhere
but even if it goes back on that
diagonal it's not actually doing all
that much
and another thing that i really like
from sevien's point of view
is that a knight c5 move can be met by
b4 so it's not like this knight can just
sit
happily on c5 no no white is going to
kick that knight out so rook 8
seems like a good starting point for uh
serrano
but i like your move h4 i'd play that
right now because bishop g4 does not
take back the diagonal and then white
plays
f3 and says get out of here my bishop's
coming to h3 where i'm starting to
pester
your knight and your pawn on b6 could
become a target
right and instead sam has decided to
play rook c2
which is sort of a multi-purpose move
and now sorana brings this other rook
into the queen side i like the
positioning of that rook on a8 it's sort
of clamping down on that file it's it's
immobilizing white
and here comes h4 now bishop h3 is even
more potent
uh because it pins the knight to the
rook so
serious problems continue uh to be posed
here by set by by sam
yeah just not a comfortable position to
play for serrano he does play knight to
c5 so i was mentioning that b4 can be
played
but i don't think he'll play it right
now because b4 you have to capture what
happens with knight to d3
the knight's jumping in it looks like
it's wandered too far and could even
maybe get trapped there but the problem
is and i'll just put this on the board
is like oh he plays bishop h3 but if b4
some kind of knight d3 maybe i'll play
c5 and get my knight back to b4 so it's
not
so so easy for white to continue and to
contain that knight on d3
but if the rook comes to c7 then if we
play b4 knight t3 we can take on b6 and
guess what
it's not about the pawn the rook is
simply trapped so
sorana goes rook v8 precisely because of
that not a move that you play
uh you know easily you play this move
with a heavy heart now savion could
consider
taking on c6 and then running that pawn
to b5
and trying to weaken the d5 square i
don't love that strategy because that
makes a lot of concessions
it lets blacks knight as you said occupy
that nasty d3 square so i'm not sure
about that maybe go rook d2 first
uh but a big decision here as sebian
goes f3 preferring that more measured
approach
making these marginal improvements to
his position just because i don't see a
good plan for
for alexi here yeah the only plan i can
think of is a knight a4
type of maneuver at some point saying
let me trade off your really
good knight or potential the great
knight on c3
as you mentioned this idea of taking on
c6 playing b4 b5 it's standard
to give me the d5 square but if i play
knight a4 well then i'm trading off your
knight before it can ever get to d5
so that's one thing i'm considering
bishop d8 rerouting the bishop to
protect the pawn on b6 is another
but black is just more passive here
dania and if i'm white i may consider
b3 you're not making any progress you're
not playing knight a4 you're not trading
knights
then i'll go king f2 i'll go king e2 and
i'll just
perfect my pieces before you can do much
of anything and that is why
serrano plays knight a4 but now if you
take on a4
rook a4 i was trying to make a move such
as bishop to d7 where the problem is
again that the a2 pawn hanging
is quite now maybe dc and then bishop d7
because knight takes c3 can be met with
bc
oh you're saying in the initial position
let me uh get back here so okay but now
again there should be some there we go
i don't like this as much though because
of c5
but it's interesting because white can
play like a4 and say you're never
doing anything on the queensland i can
eventually play b4
and the side that controls the pawn
breaks is often decided with the
advantage not always
but very often and so if i play a4 that
does
tie my bishop down though to that a4
pawn not that
the bishop has anywhere else to go at
this current moment i'm just thinking
that you know if i play a4 i cannot play
b4 unless my bishop stays
defending that pawn yeah i mean it's
interesting that serrano has been played
very quickly he's got
two minutes and right about two and a
half minutes remaining uh
and and it's one of those cases it's not
like he he doesn't care it's just that
he
in a certain sense you know there's
nothing that he can do so he
it's easier for him to just shuffle his
pieces around whereas sevien
has to time the moment when he breaks
through correctly
he's under a minute now sorana i'm sort
of insinuating
that he might want to play f5 uh which
complicates the equation for sure
so b4 maybe can even be met with f5
that's true an f5 as you're saying
most importantly it complicates things
and even if you play f6 a tamer move
and then try to go bishop to e8 to trade
off that bishop one d7
what i don't like about f6 is that this
king on g1 may work its way to g4
if the bishops get traded and into the
light squares that's something that
i have a long-term vision of and so f5
does look
much more to the point and creates a
problem for
white actually f5 now looks great
because you need to take with the rook
on f5 so
ryan said for throwing rook to d and
below 30 seconds is sevien
it's not a particularly difficult
position to play for white either of
course he could shuffle his pieces
around but if serrano drops his rook
back does he want a5
this bishop on b5 can't move right yeah
so he plays that come on how do you
defend the pawn that was missed for sure
by sam
that's a big blunder that is a blunder
he's gonna have to drop e4 and go f4 the
fortunes have changed completely look at
the time situation robert two minutes
extra on the clock and he stacks the
exchange wow he's actually exchanged
trying to make the claim that black
can't do much of anything and he's right
if white gets a
few moves if this king gets to e4 no
black is really stuck and white's king
can
become active and help him to an
initiative so king h7 played
and but then bishop g5 so
every single one of these moves involves
a concession he does bring his kingdom
toward the center i like that exchange
sack
but it has to be handled very precisely
if white is to play for a win here i
don't even know if he can
i think that black needs to try some
kind of h5 g5 like break open
the king side and the bishop on b5 still
cannot move down here so that's the good
news
for uh serrano even though his pieces
aren't doing all that much yet
he's up on the clock he has the
potential to play a move like g5
if you played g5 you made the great
point that white pushes through to h5
then can you play g4 but the king of e4
and say you're not making any progress
whatsoever
and if this rook moves away from d8
there's bishop back to d7 and that could
be a bit annoying
so he plays h5 he's i think he's trying
to play for a g5
yeah and sam is very good in time
pressure i've noticed this throughout
his blitz games he goes 85 very brave
breaking through continuing to break
through now if
if c takes b4 i guess he wants to take
on v6 with the bishop so toronto trying
to hold things together
let's see how this unfolds three maybe
if rook a3 looks good just keeping that
king on e4 in a bit of danger
six is an idea but this is potentially
stacking the bishop creating
even especially now i suspect that's to
be four instead
yeah and i'm looking at rook two eight
wait there's rook takes f3 here because
the bishop on f6 had an e4
check you devil i'm just like trying to
find really interesting
mating patterns and tactics and that was
one of them we can
show that after the game but i don't
even know if that was that great for
black because of those bishop sacrifices
you kept talking about c4 should be
considered here by the way on the same
note rook takes rook says d5 sorry and
and then roxy for check
okay or even bishop d8 there i think
rook takes b5 might be very strong here
i see your point because the pawns are
doubled in the b file and then black
star can scoop things up and bishop d8
played and i
oh right anyway can you play f4 at some
point for white
you have to there's something otherwise
there's some mating over there now
because there it goes
there's like some attack potential
against that black king now
who's gonna get checkmated now rook f4
but bishop f6
there's robert i think he missed that he
did but he could still take on that
forward with the rook and play g4 so i'm
not sure if
wait but they need to calculate rook
takes b5 rook c4 check and then the end
game
like too much going on you're gonna be
worse for white i think
so rook b5 cb rook c4 check
trade the zero five is interesting g5
hgh4
oh and then you are threatening to to
get into those i think g5 is very strong
here
that's a nice way to break the free
there but g5 there might even be rook
f5 but a gh yeah g5 check
and rook g5 is important now rook h8 and
never get changed rogue change is just
great
he had to give a check on g5 first in
order to draw the king away so it
doesn't support that square
but now will savion drum up any kind of
counter play against black's king i
don't see it
no the king actually is sitting fine on
g6 and you have a lone rook the bishops
getting back into the game but push that
pawn to h
yeah and b6 falls ceronic goes back
around to take it
sam trying to create counter play but he
just doesn't have enough pieces on the
board
rook d4 sorana's time management was
stella amazing
but wait a minute now that pawn is
defended by the bishop i'm not sure
okay well they both so many pawns h2 i
think should just be played at some
point
yeah yes just play h2 lexi just needs to
he's going to
now wait a second he hasn't played h2 oh
and he lost the seat pawn and now he
does
oh bishop before check what the
sequence
that's awesome barely got the move off
because of h1
oh came here but no i can't hold rookie
one
okay take nd7 first is prudent but rook
d1 was a possibility
rook d4 sam is so resilient
oh my gosh that g-pawn got really far
too it did but rook g8 and he's gonna
pick it off
yeah rook h6 trying to take any well so
he's giving himself a chance so seven is
doing all he can to stay in this game as
long as possible
and if somehow this pawn drops from b4
then you're not winning this game
anymore we saw this in yesterday's match
and some of these exchange down
positions when
you can't make progress all of a sudden
you blunder your pawn and boom boom goes
the dynamite
for sure and look at serrano's doing a
ladder with his rooks
oh he pre-moved bishop too bad pre-move
there
well yeah i mean it's very very hard to
defend that for a long period of time
and
so rana keeping his foot on the gas
pedal fantastic time management that
time
by alexi yeah that was a really
fun game there and i don't think if
you're seven you can be that upset
there's some
first games you lose where you're just
really frustrated and you can even start
tilting
as early as after the first game but
that felt like a true battle
you know absolutely it had its ups and
downs
he extracts the lessons maybe slightly
better time management
uh and here we have a very topical line
of the nimzo this looks crazy but it's
very well studied
uh i myself am not up to date but again
um
sebian has to be careful going to these
topical lines although he himself
let's not underestimate his preparation
which is absolutely stellar
as well didn't we see this in a previous
match
um we did we did but i'm trying to put
my finger on which one it was
this definitely did this just doesn't
look good for book what if i just go
what's the count yeah fg and opening the
rook up at the end of the day i'm going
to win
the piece back and black's king is just
going to be a lot more exposed than
whites
right and actually fg had the added
benefit of just yeah bringing your rook
into the idea i don't understand why not
fg honestly giving you the f5 square
your rook could come to f4 that looked
much better but yeah hg i think that's
the move that you're
trained to do right since you're getting
into rook h1 maybe he wants
but doesn't quite feel quite as good
and what does it say is like your
coaches right when you're a kid and
these players are still quite young but
you're coaching
you take towards the center you take
with the h-pawn
but we know that when you're under
attack you often take away from the
senator to open up your rook
for not just an aggressive plan but for
a line of defense so now knight
capture on e5 down that you could take
on b4
but i'm guessing the f3 square in
particular knight g4 coming with queen
x2 threats
wouldn't it be great robert if there was
a rook on f1 that was perhaps
controlling the f3 square
oh and if the queen on c2 were
protecting and that would that was not a
possibility was it
um acting like a good russian school boy
but maybe a little bit too dogmatically
and
by the way i just wanted to put that out
there technically i think it's
pronounced uh
saranac with the accent on the last a
okay but that's hard to say
so i'm just gonna keep saying sorana
it's a bit of an unusual last name
no no you i i always prefer being
accurate with the pronunciation so
sarana is what we're gonna say
it's not as unusual as people may think
in it's similar to the russian word
saran chap
which means locust so
well he is fun fact he's trying to
plague
sevien's chances of making the speech
his champion oh man
you are that was high level i'm just you
know donya i'm just letting you know
that i'm here we're our partners in
crime in this commentator
team so i am just trying to i'm trying
to play ball
no you are playing ball speaking of
which uh we still need to play ball at
some point
true i need to beat you of course uh
anyways now knight f3 knight h4 is a
perpetual i think
wow yeah because if okay i'll show that
knight f3 check king has to go to g2
knight h4 check
if you ever take then i have queen g4
queen h4 queen g4 etcetera right your
king goes back and forth my queen does
the same
this uh song and dance ends in a
repetition
right now savion definitely sees it he
has it in his pocket
in these situations you know why do i
feel like i'm
sort of unintentionally i was thinking
you sounded like gary even though you
weren't trying
these situations you want to you know
think take all of your time you know and
try to know think about you know how you
want to
play for a win maybe but i think yeah
you do take all of your time there's no
reason not to because there's white
literally cannot avoid the repetition
rook c8 should be considered you could
even take on e6 but there white goes
bishop b4
and there's knight g4 ideas as well
robert i really
i mean maybe fe i guess bishop b2 but
that looks a little bit scary as well
but you're right then after f takes e6
you should play bishop e2 because that
takes away f3 from the knight but also
g4 while of course attacking
the queen on h5 so that would be good
and then the problem for black is
well end games are worse for you your
pawn structure is shattered
so that's the potential downside of
playing on
is that you have a risk in the long term
whereas you have the short term
initiative so i think seven's doing the
right thing here
he's spending a good chunk of time and i
get the feeling
yeah he'll play knight f3 in it's pretty
good
okay and i think that what were you
saying about uh your feeling
yeah this is exactly what i thought was
gonna happen oh
yeah well i mean i think you're trained
as a tournament player
uh when you're playing these gm
tournaments you're usually fine
with the draw with black and we saw that
sevien got an advantage out of the
opening with whites there's no reason at
this point in the match to go
wild um and to do something you know
imprudent he's on the board he gets
the white pieces and we see here another
english
we do indeed and uh just wanted to
give a shout out to all our viewers you
know it's early in this match we still
have
well over an hour of the longest time
control left but i just want to say hey
welcome back if you're you've been
watching the jcc if you're new
hey hope you're enjoying it and keep on
watching so we have
dania the same exact line who do you
think
in the future will change it up first
and say i'm not playing this exact
english line anymore i know that
sevien has been playing english a lot in
in recent months and years
i mean right now the ball is squarely in
alexis core
because he got a passive position in the
first game
i think that we're going to see less
total change of openings and more
modifications so
sevien might change the line of the
english that he plays such as four
maybe four e3 or a3 and alexi might
deviate let's say from knight to d4 um
knowing these players are very
principled so i think we're going to see
in opening variation rather than total
change of openings that's just
you know that i'm just going from
instincts here of course we could
see a lot of different things again i
like white's position here i think
the central tension we might have seen
this exact position queen b3
was played in a position like this i
mean it just seems to me that it's
harder to play for black
i'm with you and the other game actually
the queen went to b3 before black one
queen b6 and then sam traded there so
slight difference but i'm based on your
major point there is i i would agree
with you we saw jeffrey john
play d4 and then play e4 he changed his
opening on the very first move and
arjun his opponent you know played some
karakon lines and then
ended up playing the french so those are
some big changes
whereas you're saying we won't see that
kind of switcheroo we'll see
a modification so on move five instead
of on move one
also because serana uh is a night or
expert he plays essentially exclusively
the night or against one e4
which is partially why cevian i think is
uh
not going into that uh opening because
he is
an e4 player um he wants to avoid
uh serrano's preparation in the night or
and against d4 i think
alexi also plays uh sort of almost
exclusively to the sloth
so it really depends on who these
players are
in tournament chess as well you know
with jeffrey he plays a lot of different
stuff even
in tournaments and that obviously
reflects on uh players choice in
in the speedchest championship for sure
and danny i want to make
one point about this game that's
different from the first is well now
black has taken on b3
so that's a big difference black was one
of the double pawns now it's white
but also this rook came to c8 from the
uh king side rather than the queenside
rook and that's because
sarana led with queen to b6 and that's
important
and just to go back a couple moves here
as if
uh sevian had taken on b6 now that rook
is already on
a8 where it's meant to be and the rook
is on the c file whereas in the first
game
he brought rook a to c8 and had to bring
his work back to a8 and then bring his
rook from f8 to c8 so it took
unnecessary time so serena actually has
made an
improvement i would say over that first
game he takes on d5
he is not afraid of e takes d5
because we have an asymmetrical pawn
structure in that
case and after e takes d5 maybe the
bishop gets the g6
and there's even bishop c2 on the docket
going for the b3 pawn
um that was very incisive explanation
but
i need to share with you a joke okay go
for it
uh how does alexi
grandmaster alexi preserve uh his food
for long periods of time
he uses the serrano wrap you know i was
hoping you would make a
serrano like reference instead oh
okay that would have been a different
way but i i keep close to the actual
names
wait how is that that is the you know
but
saran and havana like you're replacing
arbitrarily replacing a word with
another word that deviates from it
entirely
i'm just just letting you know that look
if that
was a contest i would say ran away with
it i would have ran away with it a long
time ago
nope nope we're not letting that happen
anyway dania talk to us about the chest
the bishop's on h3 now
it is and here's the issue uh if black
plays g6
white can consider going f3 and
literally just going after that bishop
on h5 threatening g4
if alexi goes well he goes rook f8 but
here's the problem now that rook is
tied down to the pawn and sevien could
consider going either
b4 or rook f to c1 to prepare before so
he's basically playing on both fronts
um and black's resources are stretched
uh
very thin much like
so will uh alexis actually be able to
keep everything together i think so
because b4 robert has a downside
b4 rook ac8 and white might have a hard
time keeping that c4 pawn defended
because if b3
then you could play b5 trying to exploit
that newly undefended knight on c3 so
again we saw in the first game sembian
take a lot of time in a moment like this
and again
uh saranac is up a lot of time on the
clock f4 very interesting move
he continues to operate on the king's
side uh do you agree with that comment
that actually employee of the month
because i have to put up with your
jokes
[Laughter]
but actually what you were saying was
really important because
b4 c5 that's a typical idea
uh in a position of this nature but you
have to watch out for the c4 point
typically your bishop is not on h3 your
bishop is somewhere defending that pawn
so you feel
free to move the pawn to b4 so this has
the vibes of a sicilian
right where you took on d5 at some point
and
white took back with e pawn and tries to
go for the queenside palm majority
and i like black's position because the
bishop on h5 may look a bit awkward
but now this pawn is on f4 and cannot go
to f3 to try to trap the bishop
that's an annoying bishop that at some
point can even get into a square like e2
and put some pressure on the c4 pawn i
do see what you're saying i agree
i also like the way that sevien has
handled this placing that rook on c1 to
lend reinforcement to the knight on c3
now if rook c8 he can very freely play
beat well it's happened i guess
let's see what uh sarna has cooked up
here maybe bishop d a bishop b6
that's a pretty typical idea instead he
goes rook c7 what he has to watch out
for robert
is that c5 breakthrough which can come
even if
uh that means sacrificing a pawn
sometimes c5 followed by d6 can happen
i'm not saying here but serrano's just
preparing b5 here that's actually
surprisingly hard to deal with the
knight on c3 is still very loose maybe
7 goes b5 but that in turn yields the c5
square
right and honestly i was looking at f
takes e5 because if you take with the
knight there could be some bishop b6 but
the problem is look at these
light squares that knight is about to
jump into it can just give you an
immediate force so
that doesn't quite pan out for white
i imagine and he plays bishop to g2
first
covering the f3 square and the bishop
wasn't doing anything on h3 or staring
into a pawn that was defended
so there's a lot of tension here and at
b5 which is
your idea well i can also can i consider
taking it
like i'll give you my knight and then
get a pass pawn on a6
that's a very deep idea actually that's
a very deep idea because you have that
pawn on a6 in the end
right so if i you know trade you here
and then take on uh take on a6 now i
have
these runners on the queen side oh crap
i got
the memo and don't compliment robert
keep forgetting yeah that is a nice move
hey well you know me donna i'm happy to
sacrifice other people's pieces
and absolutely the b5 plan that you've
been highlighting for a long time i've
been thinking about it
while you're talking about other things
i'm just considering how am i going to
react to that
and if i do play c5 i'm not sure i get
oh
um okay that all sort of perfect sense
it does now the question is can
alexia now turn up the knob on the
pressure
i consider breathing the sacrifice on c4
i don't think it is warranted
because when the c file opens white
could land a rook on c7
with disastrous effect so for example
bcbc
let's say you take on c4 twice white has
to move knight a2 at the end
so sarnath plays bishop f6 he does find
a way to increase that pressure on the
knight on c3 but now
robert c5 and d6 has to be considered
um sort of even more carefully because
that pawn on d6
will be undefended by a bishop that used
to be on e7 and
he does play c5 it's a great point that
you've allowed me to push to d6 so
you guys go for it and c6 only move
uh-oh and knight c5 there's knight d5
right wheels start coming off tactics
everywhere
and there could be a four oh and there's
also knight
b4 like knight c5 knight d5 i'm hitting
your bishop i'm threatening to even take
on c5 and play d7 in some ways
i'm very knight to b4 to kick your rook
from the defense of the knight this is
just
winning honestly it is the only thing is
the time situation
so we're not trying to complicate things
but he definitely underestimated the
power of a knight that lands on d5
so can you can you get away with this it
just doesn't look like it i mean this
knight d5
is so obvious i mean i don't see what
else you can do i mean you can go bishop
f3 but that
is a very temporary bulwark against with
the pressure me white could go b4 king
f2 i mean that
that's not a sustainable defense is
there a difference if you throw an ef4
so that the h4 pawn is hanging so that's
a big difference because in these lines
of knight to d5 maybe i will have some
kind of bishop takes h4
which not only attacks the rook and
traps it but
defends the d8 square in case you push
okay i just saw the evaluation bar just
so that was about oh whoa
that i did not see that no very good
what if i
take it and play bishop d4 and then
right yeah he said it's all about that
one pass fun and then rookie seven no
that's a crushing idea i think robert
yeah because you're rookie a check first
even and then it just
okay that's a good i mean i could see a
case being made for that because now c6
is a devastating threat
right so c6 is devastating you can okay
somebody before
exactly you walked into the fort
and serrano realizes that you can tell
by that pause yeah
it's over and i can't tell if he's in
hot water because of the game or because
the sauna that seems to be in his
background
but either way you know here we see that
white is up a piece
and trading off is not going to help
down goes a6 bishop d6 first you take on
a6
you're going to take on b5 in the second
and your b pawn will grow
yeah and uh the technique and i've been
impressed throughout
the jscc matches by the technique uh
conversion technique of these players
which is sort of traditionally something
that you know young players sometimes
struggle with but
uh not in this tournament their their
technique their positional understanding
has been
superb throughout with that being said
right three seconds he's got to
demonstrate
some precision here as the king has made
its way to b5 a commanding
blockading goes out g5 yeah what about
g5 oh whoa whoa whoa
then bishop e7
bishop c3 but is this winning because
the pawns
this is not going to be easy by the way
f4 and black just stays put
if the game takes on g5 then the pawn
rushes to f2 and distracts the bishop
yeah you're right and you're just
complimenting the technique so you oh
wait the evaluation bar just what did
you oh wait
it's yourself oh it's king d5 no king d5
was the wrong way
b5 is okay we need to draw let's look at
their faces because
unbelievable oh my gosh
miraculous wait was i missing anything
roberto king b5 is just a draw
it was i'm going to bring up that
analysis board because oh my lands
disbelief by saranac there he just like
what happened and we're getting a repeat
of the opening so let's bring up quickly
that position because king d5 was a
major mistake he was bringing his king
closer to his pawns
but he needed to stay attached to the b4
pawn if king f5
you'd point this out dania that you just
jettison this pawn
and you win the b4 pawn and that's a
draw king and bishop cannot checkmate
king so that was a missed opportunity
just one more time back here he went to
d5
no no because his king wasn't attached
to this pawn so in that sequence
just to finish that off now i can just
take bring my bishop back and win
with my past pawn so an unfortunate
series of events there for
sarana we get back to the live position
and whoa we had a repeat of the line
and something has changed here he hasn't
taken acg but again this looks
very very dubious for black well he took
on d7 first the last time he took on
c3 and then there was a b c f g or
something like that and then he took
with the h
here he took on d7 first and now
this has changed where black doesn't
have that knight coming to e5 so
what is this line the evaluation bar i
see it off to the side here it says it's
in black's favor
i don't imagine that trading queens
could ever be good for black because
they just
trade and then take on b4 so that leaves
team g7 rook h8 and checkmate down the
h5
i mean i still don't understand why
white didn't play fg
uh earlier i mean it seems like he's
setting himself up for that attack on
the h file
clearly there is a reason for it that
you know i just
don't fully understand because i'm not
uh you know
knowledgeable enough in this line after
king g7 robert the more i look at this
position initially i thought
why is the one attacking but white is
the one making a lot of noise but as you
said once a rook lands on h8
black doesn't need to make a lot of
noise all he can do is just deliver
checkmate
yeah well the noise is it's you once you
tune it out and you just let it play
itself
through it's like well what what does it
actually help you you stole you would
want to put this pump back on h7 whoa
e6 what is happening in this something
tells me this is
some sorry not home cooking what if i
just take it
yeah or not what if you take it i'm
really trying to figure out that that
wasn't meant g6 is an idea to force the
free trade but after queen takes
bishop takes bishop takes c3
right so i don't take the bishop right
away i take the pawn i'm hitting
multiple things and i'm going to take
your bishop next move
um you want to explain e6 to me a little
more what's the downside of pawn takes
e6
because i still have rook h8 ideas i'm
still attacking your pawn on c3 which is
pinned
i think i know what savion is trying to
determine and that is
what is the downside of ftx there must
be something
because the pawn is on e6 the seventh
rank is over so maybe there's some kind
of queen b2 queen b7
or rook b1 rook b7 where there's like a
problem or exactly
is that or it could just be a bluff but
i'm trying to work my way through this
and look at sarana's time he spent eight
seconds for the entire game definitely i
don't think it's a bluff
well we're about to find out buckle your
seatbelts oh and look at that so by the
way i just noticed the evaluation bar
and went to zeros and before was like
minus one and a half
so something in this line the engine
relatively low depth right
i'm just trying to help assist everybody
to see you know
can't catch up with our words you can
see on the screen who's better
it's caught up now it's zeros i think
queenie two might it might survive
because queen e2 uh if queen takes two
knight takes e2 and very importantly the
knight defends
well it doesn't actually defend the c3
pawn but if bishop takes e3
white doesn't have to waste time moving
his rook he can take the bishop
so why was e6 necessary in that equation
oh i see the big difference if queen e2
the queen takes h7
the difference is you no longer control
the g4 square
and i also have the e5 square available
to me so if i take
and you try rook h8 i might have some
queen e5 checks and queen g4 checks and
that may save the day
right i mean i find it hard to believe
that this definitely was not in
serrano's preparation e6 was just a move
he kind of threw out there
um i think he is going to find queenie
too just by process of elimination i
don't see any other way to even reach a
playable position i think
all other moves you can essentially
resign well what about this
one same idea but i mean now i look at
the bars as minus 2.6 so that was not
as good of an execution i think because
now queen takes age 7 and rook hay
does look very scary robert but there's
still this g4 square you have to deal
with
okay but queen g4 i'll move the king and
if you go queen h4 i'll take it and go
rook giant and checkmate you
thought you knew a lot to consider right
where's the time mcqueen takes h7
and you know the queen does get to g4
but dania's saying that he's very quick
uh on the h5 which is right totally fair
even in the event of a queen trade
uh that king on g1 is confined it could
go rook g8 check down the open g file
drive the king to the h file
and deliver a ladder checkmate so dania
there's not even queen g4 i mean look at
this queen h7 c takes b
if you go quincy for check first you go
k8 ct before e5
oh that's beautiful and you just go
after the piece yeah i'm going after the
piece and if you take
immediately on b4 i have e5 to start
with taking away your
check on g4 so the queen on e2 was
essential to stop
e5 from being played because now the
bishop covers the diagonal here comes
rook h8 if your knight moves i also have
bishop c6 going for checkmate
oh and ooh not a is not a fiber move
here
knight f5 who are you i'm dr
jenkins can i can i move my king to g8
it's important to move it to ga but then
queen g4 check and queen d4
ah i see i think so queen g4 check king
h8
okay let's let's d4 check so knight f5
check let's start here
right what if i just take on f5
oh you're going to check take and then
go queen d4g yeah exactly right here
let's show everybody here check rook f7
queen d4
you get the bishop back and now white's
i'm
going to be frank here i think
alexi is just not spending enough time
evaluating the tactical subtleties he's
just
you know he's making these tempting
moves but and he's he's sort of relying
on
uh savion's doubt in the fact that it's
as clear as it
seems to be but sevien is is is
confident in himself he is going to call
uh sorana's bluff and this is going to
backfire there is enough time in the
five minute portion to do that
so i'm really not a big fan right now of
the strategy of playing really fast and
you know not really doing a lot of
calculation i think this is really
really bad for white
i'm with you donna and i think that in
these type of variations because
some people like hey can you show me the
sharpest lines i want to checkmate my
opponent
but in these super sharp lines there are
situations where if you make
one inaccuracy not even a blunder right
it's not like
saranac blundered a piece no no he just
missed an idea
he's still up upon the position but as
we see to the left of the screen here
he's busted and so that's the problem
with playing these
really sharp lines is you could just
fall apart instantly
whereas if you play a closed position
where you're slightly worse
yeah you'll suffer but you may not have
the same risk of just
having the game end in a couple turns so
that's just a trade-off
i would say stylistically sarana is a
very aggressive player and he plays
sharp long theoretical lines we saw him
do that against
magnus carlsen in the isle of man where
he went into this end game from a
sicilian and
tried to outplay magnus from there the
game ended in the draw but
here it is clearly backfired yeah i mean
even the most well-prepared players it's
easy to confuse and forget stuff given
the amount of
just uh amount of variations and
openings that
uh any professional player has to keep
in his mind especially a professional
player who has a repertoire as
topical and sharp uh as alexi does
so it's understandable uh but i agree i
think he needs to modify
his opening approach slightly um and
you know if he's a d4 player he's going
to continue playing d4
but maybe going into a somewhat less
sharp line i'm sure he has something in
reserve as he dips below a minute here
he's
just not finding anything and i don't
think anything exists there's just too
many threats
against white's king and against that
open h file yeah it's fine like knight
f3 to bring your knight to h4 to close
things down there's bishop g4 right just
pin the knight and
i guess bishop g4 knight g5 was
something i was considering
oh my gosh you're a frustrating oh but
there's an amazing idea
okay bishop g4 probably doesn't work
yeah knight g5
yep and now it definitely doesn't work i
was going to take on d1
uh-huh and knight takes f uh knight
takes h7 i was going to go bishop f3
yeah it doesn't work according to this
it doesn't work because it's knight
but if you take the rook i just wanted
to show that rook takes f8 there is no
way to stop
the idea of rook h8 rook h1 as slow as
it is
i don't think there's any way to stop
that but it doesn't work oh well we
actually are seeing this variation
so knight g5 was played yeah but i
wouldn't take the queen here i would not
move the queen queen h5 but then a6
oh my gosh you're just the most
important f6 i would just do that and go
king f6 and win the night
but you're finding all these tactical
resources but you're right 96 just king
f6
and what if f3 here f3 i think i could
just take your knight
i take yours your bishop queen e3 check
and queen e4
check and like rooksy i don't know there
must be some kind of mate
yeah but but then i have queen d7
yeah i think f6 is important here
so king f6 is good if i run to the
corner you may have queen d7
stuff right it's hard to play
down on the clock and he's down below 20
seconds here that is the danger
of dipping so far down in the clock he
does go king f6 and there's going to be
bishop e6 like f4 so he's very careful
yeah f4 that's because the bishop
that's a great move there king comes to
g6 you have f5
under control yeah five in rook 81
robert this is not over
i definitely don't think it's over but
at least he has found a way to make his
king feel safer for the time being the
king can slide back to h7
d7 is under your control no he plays
rookie six trading off pieces
solid as a rock but now if he trades and
simply goes rook
yeah rook c1 king is not out of the
woods well neither king is
obviously oh i don't like queen h5 it
just feels like you're walking away from
your king here queen f5 played
steals b7 uh-oh now bishop d5 though
rookie six and he defends against the
checks now white's king is the one who's
going to come under fire gta
play quincy a oh
yeah he's too many threats here now f5
and but it's over
yes on time what a crazy game that was
indeed almost worked his way out of that
position he
went wrong somewhere you know his you
want to stray from what the
variations should look like and it did
get crazy
but credit to samsevian he held it
together
he did and king found king f6 he took uh
a good amount of time but he trusted
himself you know
it's very easy to say well of course he
found these these simple moves
but you know when you're in the heat of
the moment you're facing someone who is
known as
a theoretician as someone who uh you
know knows what he's doing in the
opening it's very easy to doubt yourself
and
somebody who is able to remain confident
as sevien did deserves uh praise just
for that
as we see um i guess i i stand corrected
we see another repeat of the same exact
line
yeah you know we're only moving 13 so
it's
you know not a big deal they've just
repeating the same line that's a huge
deal okay
it's a huge deal robert that's all we
want to talk about oh queen a4 no more
queen b3 business
okay so there's pressure on the c6 pawn
now
and does sarah not take on d5 or does he
protect the c
pawn well i like the idea of taking
because white can't really take with a
knight that e2 pawn is going to fall
um but maybe cd white does
have g4 he does decide to keep the
tension though and again we see e4 which
is a move we
kind of discussed previously but it's a
bit of a different iteration here with
the queen being on a4 it adds
different kind of dynamic to the
position and it does prevent knight to
d7 we've seen that idea played in
both games thus far the queen air force
says yeah you can't get there
so he's thinking right now and is there
some sort of g4
probably not because there's d4 for
black and that actually
and rook takes c4 as well so that's not
even a possibility i guess
so what is he considering just trying to
figure out which one to take
yeah but cdc i was going to say what i
like here for black there's queen d4 as
an idea
there is there's many ideas here you can
play a6 and then drop the queen back and
go for b5
he does that i like that um bishop
robin's white bishop is tied down
exactly guys about to say bishop e3 is
the movie you want to play we need
to be two pawns hanging i would go queen
a3 and get that bishop out queen e3 is a
really good move because i think
when you look at the b2 pawn a lot of
people say queen c2
towards the center but you're walking
right into a pin not the biggest deal in
the world but can be annoying
so queen a3 defends the b2 pawn although
it does allow him like queen c5
in black can try to trade queens right
that is true
um but with that if there's rook b1
which is a blunder to do rook takes c3
that's important to point out and he
does go queen a3
you need circulation among your ranks
here if you have an entire side of the
board that's
it's not moving uh that's not going to
bode well given that black has most of
his resources on the queen side
we see now this very interesting
maneuvering battle who is going to
prevail on the queen side is black going
to manage
to get b7 b5 in or is white going to
coordinate along the c
file and uh black has some holes there
bishop e3 knight a4 and ip6 comes to
mind
either side could prevail on that flank
robber yeah knight d7
is bringing another piece from the king
side over
to the center and eventually the queen
side so the 97 is fine
this bishop on h5 it continues to be
an issue and white as per usual can play
pawn to
h4 and try to improve the location of
the bishop coming to h3 so that's
likely something we're going to see in
this game right now indeed and for black
he could consider b5 but
that entails its own calculus knight c5
very again very typical placement
and again we see this does white play b4
um before knight
d3 might there might be rook cd1
and that knight might be trapped so
actually i would very seriously consider
it before here
right and i'm just showing that uh
evaluation the variation through to its
conclusion the knight gets trapped so
even though you took a rook for just a
bishop the knight goes down as well
and i get two minor pieces for my rook
but after b4 black goes knight back to
d7 and look at that c4 square the knight
could redirect itself
over on over to b6 and then to c4 so
pawns do not go backwards as um you know
the great marcus
rally is the roman philosophers talked
about and um
i guess evian realizes that but
we'll see well for sarana it's
pretty easy knight d3 gets trapped
because of rook c to d1
so then you have to go knight to d7 and
he is thinking at
this point so oh okay so what is it
cd1 doesn't work somehow but why why
does something look oh no i mean
look at the barge i'm i am oh the bar
yeah it works maybe it's time for that
night to go to the bar
true yeah or alexis
yeah i wonder what he was thinking
though because he plays knight d3 he
just means he honestly must have just
thought that rook d1 was impossible
because the bishops on h5 just
overlooked it he thought rook c2 was
forced and then black has a5 and you
know the pawns come to the rescue of the
knight
you can just see well it's not over
let's be very clear knight takes f2
white has
we have to put things in perspective
your white has two pieces for a rook now
savion is actually considering taking
the knight
amazingly that also attacks on it but
there's no need for uh those kinds of
gymnastics and
if i were alexi yeah he gives up the
knight for a pawn
i would try to put things in perspective
here and say okay i've got a rook for
two pieces i've got that c4 square now
for my rook
white has a very difficult technical
task ahead of him
agreed it's not going to be a
straightforward win for white but
clearly
savion's position is much better but b5
is a good start you can get rooks to c4
to double your rooks at some point you
may play a5 to b4 but if you ever push
this a pawn
the b5 it's not just for the pawns with
the squares on the queen side and that's
why bishop came back i like that one
here
bishop g5 let's trade bishops and the d6
pawn becomes weaker
but looser protection of the queens and
squares on white's end
as well yeah and if you take on g5 and
try to
play a4 to sort of make inroads on the
queen side you have to watch the move a5
in general because that knight on c3
is somewhat undefended only the queen is
defending it and
uh sebian needs to keep an eye on that
knight
so i just off the top of my head i'm not
exactly sure
what the most prudent way of sort of
making inroads is maybe you want to take
on g5 and go knight e1
and just redirect that knight over to d2
and then b3
but that does seem a little bit too slow
another idea i would say
is you know i don't want to allow you to
take me on e3 that's clear to me so if i
take on g5 queen g5 and then play bishop
to d3
that way i can put my knight on e
tabasco sauce right there but is that
going to backfire
that was not what i was expecting
because he's voluntarily making his king
a bit weaker but gaining some space and
he's saying i have the two minor pieces
i can do this my king is not going to be
attacked by what a lone queen right so
fast
i don't like it i don't know i don't
like it at all i mean what if i take on
a fourth queen
i guess 92 but then rook c4 i mean
it's just white is not able and i think
he realizes it now you can tell always
by the pause
in between moves that are somewhat
forced
he's thinking oh man i didn't evaluate
this probably queen h492 rook c4
the position to collapse in two moves
there is queen to b1 so it's not
totally collapsing but it looks not very
good so but even dinosaur queen h4
92 this is protecting the rook uh and
the knight's coming to defend the g3
square rook c4 i think queen b1 to
defend
the pawn and the rook and if corrupted
c4 don't like bishop f2
oh yeah you do right i think we need
seven oh your queen is coming back so i
don't even have bishop f2 so what's
going on here this is
i guess i take you take and now we have
a whole new
new game look at what he's done he has
given i like what he's done he's given
up at four but at least
he keeps his pieces uh close to the
chest at least he's not going to lose
any of them
but now it's two pawns and a rook for
the two-minute pieces and
white has the worst king so knight comes
to d4 that's looking at the c6 square
and that's going to be a huge pain for
black to deal with but then maybe black
can say let me go rook e8 and focus
in the center rather than the queen side
that's a great idea just ignore the c6
square all together
focus on building your assets serenado's
bishop before activating the bishop
taking the e5 square under even further
control
now the knight could go to f5 but i'm
not sure it will be stable there
on account of g6 i'm not sure black
would want to go g6 immediately
for now fighting his time is seven with
queen b3 but now you've got to watch for
bishop d2 and rook c3 ideas
true and i was just looking at bishop
h2j excuse me but king g2 keeps this
bishop safe and sound but
coming up with different ideas here
trying to infiltrate
with the pieces bishop d2 looks good and
followed by rook c3 i like that idea
uh what else can you play here rook this
rook
doesn't exactly have another square on
the c file to work with because we play
rook c7 then knight c6 makes you work on
cc yeah this idea of knight c6 i think
raises the urgency and he does go bishop
d2
so c3 is going to be unpleasant well
which uh score do you go to e2 or d1
with this rook
well wherever you go you need to make a
decision right now
yeah he plays it you're not threatening
rook takes d2 because of queen g5
good call very good vision there so
that's not a threat so rook c3 does
still work out you could always throw in
queens if i check if you need it he
plays rook c3
and now wait wait bishop e3 might be
good because you can't take my rook
because i have queen takes up two check
and i'm just trying to remove one of
your
very important defenders of your king
aha i really like that call maybe knight
f5 then
trying to throw that blanket over oh
it's getting live
there's a discovery a possibility there
if the knight moves so if the bishop
moves away from e3
rook g3 is going to be a threat i mean
this is so hard to play for white though
and he does go bishop
bishop c5 is kind of a nasty move right
threatening rook g3 and you cannot move
the king anywhere maybe you go bishop g2
there
covering the king as best you can
watch out for rook g3 oh bishop g2 there
might be
there's some three d3 yeah this is
getting complex
so what if what if i just take and play
rook to c8 like can i just
do that and go after the dark scores
later i completely agree you could go
rook see it even immediately but i
i don't see any particular reason to
keep the tension
and i guess one move for white is knight
to d4 next just to keep the bishops on
whoa that was played and bishop takes c5
oh wait there's some problems with the
dark squares there are he's just created
some big wheat i would go king faith
then bishop g to rook f1 maybe uh-oh
queen
yeah that's not the end of the world
though king h-a
because white's own king is also very
weak this is going to be a time scramble
buckle up
okay so queen d4 check and then f6 and
then rook d2 rook f2 okay he goes
bishop g2 to go rook up one he doubles
but rook of one is rookie c1 very
importantly
very important move trading off the
rooks at the last second he takes now
black is better again age five
well what's up queen e7 check watch out
for that check stop saying
oh good vision there queen g5 is
possible queen
might just be winning but then there's
take take knight f3 you have to
calculate the e5 pawn break
the queen rook c2
wait for queen a7 and knight g4 oh g4
what a scene
runs where's the h
h5 coming no but we're not six of spades
okay
okay he he had h5 at some point but now
rooks he won oh
oh that's a buzz kill yeah that's
everything for lapses
what a game yeah we're like it's also
saying the same thing today it's
worrying me yeah somehow we're on the
same page that's not good robert we need
to
we really need to change oh my
gosh what a crazy game that was
absolutely i mean that was
just they had all of the ingredients of
high-level the kind of high-level chess
that we've been seeing
day in and day out at the jfcc and
we have to acknowledge it serrano
blundered he put his knight on d3 he
missed rook c to d1
but he kept his composure and that's
really important because the game is not
won or lost often at the first mistake
it's what happens
as you get into time trouble as the game
continues so we have a two and a half
two and a half start
after five games sarana has the white
pieces
and speaking of sharp chest dania these
kind of anti-moscows
what to what to take about this it it is
um
it's it's a crazy together with a
bottleneck which we saw once yesterday
this is what i would consider to be the
sister
uh or the cousin or choose your relative
of the batmanic
where black does cling to that pawn on
c4 but it doesn't take
um a long time to see that white's got a
lot of compensation in the form of
central control in the form of the fact
that black
i mean black's position could collapse
very very easily here there's a lot of
peace sacrifices
uh kind of the style of the king's
gambit actually where you just leave
your knight on c3 well he has now he
hasn't sacked the piece
because he takes on f6 but black has to
handle this very precisely black's king
for the time being is stranded in the
center so if there are files that open
such as the b file
the attack could come very very fast and
i see that the
bar is going up in white's favor super
complex variation
i would take on h8 and take on a1 and
then
c4 is probably going to fall and even if
black castle's long
because that before it's what i
mentioned because that b file has opened
black's king just does not have any safe
place to go to but
alexi chooses rook b1 yeah he has book
h6 bishop g5 with tempo
keeping the king stuck in the center and
he will regain this pawn on b2 so that's
his claim
c4 will also fall you made a mention of
that so what's the current material
count
black has all eight pawns even though
they're scrambled across the board
white has six pawns two extra pawns for
black but once b2 and c4 fall that's
restores material quality and black's
king is in worse shape white's king on
g1 is
safe and sound for the time being but
dinah there are sometimes these
ideas where black plays move like g3 to
open up the king on g1 something to
consider
is while the king looks safe for now you
have pushed your pawn to h4
and that has some drawbacks as well yeah
that's a great point
wherever there is a pawn like that you
know white has to keep an eye on it now
here's a thought after rook h6 bishop
bishop g5
could black try c3 i realize it looks
completely unsustainable but if you take
that rook on h6 notice that black's
bishop can then swing over to d2
and defend c3 so i don't believe in that
but i
i think that sevien needs to be very
concerned here because
despite the two extra pawns he's going
to lose one of them um so i would
consider a c3 here
almost as a desperate measure but the
problem is serrano could go queen b3 he
doesn't even have to take the rook
yeah i was saying queen d3 as well just
to get this pawn back he plays queen b3
which is better i was looking at
queen takes d4 but i forgot the bishop
mb7 would be hanging so queen d3 my idea
was that
hey i'm still attacking your pawn and
bishop v4 was never possible because the
bishop is needed to defend the brook
but same idea different execution you
are losing your pawn on c3
and then down goes b2 after that right
right
and then you won't even have a pawn for
your suffering
i could see this ending in the next ten
moves that's the downside of these lines
for black robert is is you need to
handle them so well sebian
is a slav player he's he he knows the
bot he's a specialist in the batmanic
variation
um but alexi made a very good choice by
going for
uh this the moscow variation i think
it's a little less familiar
that's just heavy than the botany for
sure and
look at the time situation by the way
sarana has four minutes and 20 seconds
and
sevien down to two minutes he has less
time
his position is not very good he also
lost the previous game which could
fluster him a bit
and for serrano he's looking to take the
lead once again he had the lead after
the first game of the match then savion
stormed back
and now it's sarina these kind of back
and forth
the seesaws will happen in such a long
match look at the time situation in the
three-minute portion looking forward
it's going to be important for for
sevien to stabilize the ship i mean
almost
three minute advantage for sarina and i
was a little bit critical of that
strategy
uh in the previous two games ago uh in
certain positions but that is not to say
he's not very well prepared and
confident and those things are obviously
very good
uh as we can see here he's supremely
confident in these positions
and he's playing flawless game leaving
himself with tons of time
for the conversion phase okay a5 is
a good move all things to put the bishop
on b4 that's actually
it was a really smart it was by
because what do you do now i mean f3 is
an idea too potentially right f4
that's true f3 is an idea i'm looking at
the center and looking at d4 and e4 i'm
like
that looks good but i could see black
turning around and attacking that center
and the bishop one before
has stabilized thanks to this pawn on a5
and an eventual c5 move could be a bit
annoying
g3 is possible here but then i could go
f4 and
ram that on through to f5 yeah that
doesn't look very good
the problem again as we discussed the
king has no safe haven maybe sevilla
needs to find a way to attack that d4
pawn that seems to be the only
tender spot in white's camp but look at
that bishop on g5
not only is it a thorn in black's throat
it's also guarding the d8 square
and he plays c5 he had to right he has
to go after the d4 but i would play d5
i'm not opening this position up for
black's pieces
and d5 keeps things closed and the king
on f8 is in the most danger
and if he takes d5 then i was going to
probably take on g4 but
i didn't calculate it thoroughly i just
thought the key would be didn't
calculate thoroughly that's unacceptable
i calculate every recommendation of
course you do so rook takes before f
takes g4 how do you feel about that
no you have to do that rook takes before
is to kind of move that plate that
your hand just makes that movement man
your brain
has to approve of it or there will be
rebellion
because we keep talking about the king
being stuck here
and if i allow well bishop c5 now is
disastrous because it's a pin and
winning the queen but i just see black
coming back if you just allow some
activity and rook to see one that feels
like you're going the wrong direction
you're keeping your extra pawn
but you're losing your attacking chances
so i would
focus on the attack rook takes b4
politics for punting g4
opening this rook up just trying to get
after this rook on g6 as well
i don't really see how black meets that
i could see a case being made for rook
c2 here
sort of i suppose in the style of a
computer saying all right i'm not
actually going to give you any material
but i am
obviously on board with you what about
the pawn a4 if you like rook c2
yeah and i was going to go rook c1 there
wait takes a 4 rook c1
but i have queen a3 in those kind of
positions
but no i completely agree with you like
even though white's better
we know that it just with the queen's
off the board it gives some better
chances for black
i would argue after queen a3 if we look
concretely i would go queen f4
and i know alexi he does it he doubles
on the c poker that i'm not sure about
but yeah look at the the bar next to the
board it went
really down and queen e3 didn't like
though no
it hated queen d4 maybe ooh
no you didn't queen h8 is a devastating
threat yeah yeah nc6 is also a threat
and the difference is the rooks doubled
here protects c5 he goes queen f4 which
is still going to be good
bishop c5 rook takes c5 would have won
tactically
because of a check on d6 c6 now and
bishop a6 do you just promote the pawn
you just say you know what i i'm a man
of simple taste i'm gonna promote that
pawn
that's so painful like you you're trying
to
stop the attack which you might not even
be successful in doing and then bishop
a6 happens and
here comes c7c and that is uh
something that we've referenced as
savion trying to muddy the waters here
with e5
as he should but oh because that rook on
g6 now it's all of a sudden attacking
c6 so sir has to be accurate here it
takes an e5 there's queens
yeah right you go after the material
you don't always go after checkmate
sometimes you just go after the material
when you're attacking and that can be
the most effective
foolproof strategy and here queen c3
forces the queens off the board because
the rook tries to block kate on c7
there's bishop to d8 so i mean among
other things that should be
good enough he plays queen wait
disrupted 466.
oh my lance oh i suggested and of course
it's bad
he misses it no but now c7 bishop c7 is
his idea there's no way that i can work
no way i mean even what f4 here just
push that pawn through
then f6 maybe yeah
but now just f g i mean the pieces start
falling apart for for saving because f6
bishop h5
nice yeah and now bishop f4 i mean
anything is bishop d7 bishop f4
nice yeah this is this is over
yeah but this is one that was a big
chance
and it's funny because that discovery
still was in my mind so i was
using fg and icing f4 i was just trying
to stop the bishop checks
but he he misses one chance to
stay in the game there now he has 2.7
seconds left there's a passport on c6
he's alive but how is he doing this c6 i
don't
understand uh rook takes a four bishop
c6 rook c4
okay it's kind of serrano has to be
careful i mean that king on h3 is not
entirely safe
but no it's just yeah it's a free piece
yeah okay
and i wonder uh for sam if he's looking
forward to the quicker time patrols or
if he'd prefer
to play more in the
longer one because he's playing this i
mean yeah it's so evenly matched that i
think they both
don't necessarily have a preference in
this case uh but yeah maybe just like
inertia so 25 minutes left
it's been you know neck and neck in
these games
yeah let's bring up that board yeah from
the last game once more just show that
tactic that was overlooked
by uh sevien he was on the defensive he
didn't have much time
but things at this point here the queen
trade which i suggested
turns out to be not so good because rook
takes c6
rook c6 bishop c6 oxide point is
this is immune because bishop h2 check
and
i guess i don't know it's it's still
looks good for white
yeah but well yeah of course black is
still worse but comparatively speaking
robert i mean this would be
big turn of events and you might look at
it and say well two bishops for a rook
is better but look at that pass upon
that's the whole point right
right that does give you a chance and
bishops are obviously on the opposite
color the two bishops
and you can't team up on squares so
there could be a way for black to try
and hold
it so would be good for white so let's
go back to the current
game as hey can i get wait
this is from the english but there's a
pawn on c3 so clearly there's a trait on
that square can i give myself a pat on
the back here
because you said four e3 and it happened
well i said that's
i said that he would keep the same
openings but change the variation that's
what he did
yeah he's playing the sort of carlson
way where you
push the pawn e4 and serrano is actually
dealing with this quite well
yes because in the way that white has
played this you've given up
some light square control you're still
fighting for the center on the d4 and e5
squares
and right now this is a critical moment
because i
was thinking i'm obviously i don't think
you want to take on d4 but maybe
tactically
there's some kind of knight before maybe
four yeah it also almost reminds me of a
ryan lopez for some reason which i can't
put my finger on uh is it because
there's a pawn on e4
and you just took on d4 and yeah okay
well knight before idea exists also in
c5
undertone not that he's going to play it
okay so he does it i'm
again the speed with which he goes for
this line because even after a knight
before
it's not like when you take on a2 or
whatever
oh i don't do this i don't know how to
do this like do i go over k2 first do i
play knight to b4
um or nothing or do you go if rookie
eight i don't know
well he decided to move first and think
later he didn't play for d8 okay
that's probably the one e5 then i have
knight d5 like you're giving me
something
oh you're gonna check me he's so
confident i mean i to me i would be like
i would be terrified here
even queen takes c4 bishop d5 i mean
everything has to be considered
i like that where you take two pieces
for the queen and then you threaten f7
you threaten c6 it probably doesn't pan
out
take one page out of your book
sacrificing others i'm into it let's
just look at it we're analyzing queen c4
bc4 bishop takes d5 and
[Music]
i'm you know who doesn't like it
uh mr grandmaster bar yeah master bar
mr barr is not a fan of the sacrifice it
looks good to me
just by good i mean it looks pretty cool
but i guess you could probably just even
take on e5 or something like that
right then bishop c6 pawn d4 i don't
know it's too much to calculate
starting to look good for black though
yeah no it's
too little stuff now 94 is a far more
measured and prudent move
look at those dark squares i mean those
dark squares are going to be in alexis
nightmares
they certainly will and knight speak
well there's not going to be
four queen d2 and queen h6 you're just
so focused on the checkmate
give me a break so what about rook takes
a2 now and i take with the knight on a2
and at least i hit your bishop on c1 i
don't care i'm gonna go queen h6 anyway
you take my rook on a1 you knock
yourself out no but then knight g5 will
attack my queen
that's what i'm trying to do you you uh
started it with the queen sack
i'm returning the fear we're going to
look at this line very quickly rook
takes
knight takes queen h6 so he's going to
take on c1 you're going to go knight g5
to try to checkmate me on h7 i was going
to throw in a check on you too and then
probably sacrifice my question
just just so you know but i don't even
know if it works
no i definitely i think it does and
that's that's one thing robert
when when you're going after checkmate
it can be very easy to lose track of how
much you've sacrificed and all of a
sudden your opponent gives up his queen
you say ah i've succeeded you know i
wanted the queen but you've stacked you
know like two rooks in two pieces
and all of a sudden you have no pieces
left so
now alexia has taken on e5 posing uh sam
with
that very same decision does he go queen
h6 or does he actually take
back on e5 and open up that d file which
might be to black's favor
right queen h6 there are even ideas
eventually with knight to c2
you know tactically could potentially
pan out knight to d3 as
well it's tough to evaluate such a
position
because white could be in danger of
losing several pawns
but the king on g8 is so unsafe so he
does go with queen h6
and f6 is one idea don't love it
but it's a way to try to stop a piece of
point in g5
i suppose f6d e i guess is what he wants
and then if rookie five bishop b2 now if
you go knight c2 here
one line would be okay so he's taken
so knight g5 knight f6 i guess protects
h7 and
there's also queen f6 where you give the
h7 pawn
but you save your king so rook d4 is to
be considered here
d5 and bishop g5 i think
but that's also very complicated for
bishop b2 i think rook takes d5 and
bishop b2 is the key
okay so like rook d4 knight c2 using
rook d5 bishop d5 bishop
yes two defensive yeah that's just
you're
crushing me on the dark squares yeah
yeah yeah so
that's not good so rook d4 played he's
got to find a move here
maybe f5 f5 what can i also the queen e7
to get out of this pin
then i maybe go bishop b2 but i
understand then you go f5
and i also have queen fate as well maybe
to try to trade the queens
i'm getting desperate i'm being honest
with you i'm getting like ultra
defensive
no but i understand what you're saying i
mean i'm at first i thought it's
crushing because of the dark script but
with the files being open notice that
the knight is kind of immobilized
because of the threat of rookie one at
least until the bishop moves out
oh my gosh and actually after f5 there's
queenie one check
in some variations you have to be very
careful
although then it takes and go bishop out
so that's not mate but it is very
dangerous i agree
right so what a weird position we have
and and i don't envy the players with
two minutes especially essentially
on both of their clocks to calculate
these insane complications
yeah and this is where i want to just
say robert and i think you'll side with
me here
you can look at the eval bar and say
well it's so simple you know this this
and this
or you look at the computer's top choice
how can they miss it uh it's very
important to understand how complicated
this position is the computer
makes everything seem simple but try to
understand the sort of nuance and
complexity and the amount of candidate
moves
that need to be calculated here bishop
b2 is what occurred to me bishop b2 fb
rook d5
ooh because you have what about queen e7
after bishop b2
but then i was going to suggest i was
going to suggest
rookie one maybe there okay he's got
bishop with tempo
oh but queen d7 there's knight f6 right
that's a problem
although you would sack your queen oh
the brook and aids hanging
that's uh something i didn't notice at
first but like queen d7
knight f6 check takes you can you take
with the bishop on f6 but rook d7 97 the
rook on 8 is hanging at the end
and so white has a ton of extra material
right
he's taken on e4 but this has the error
of desperation i mean you could take on
d8 and go back to f6
and use that pin to win oh granted black
will have two
pieces for a queen it's not entirely
over there but i think it essentially is
yeah and he's done precisely that good
eye by you there we'll just
say it again bishop f6 threatening
checkmate in one
threatening the rook the knight is well
it can capture as it just did but you
lose
the rook on eight and done one other
thing that i want to say
kind of what you were implying is um
it is difficult to go through all of
these immense complications for the
players
and i also think when we make mistakes i
am never
ashamed of my mistakes and part of the
reason why is like when i see the
evaluation part jump i'm like okay
clearly i didn't see something but we're
also going through that same process of
there are so many different
possibilities and that queen sacks that
we're talking about earlier those look
very interesting
and if we were playing we wouldn't have
an evaluation bar so we'd just be like
hey this looks like good compensation
and compensation
isn't always concrete it's more like
this gives me a chance
and so the players if they blunder if
they make some kind of inaccuracy
it's almost always not a one move thing
it's usually like oh
shoot i missed the fourth move down that
you know third variation that i was
calculating
so yeah no i i could totally yeah
completely agree with you robert and you
know one analogy i make sometimes
is the basketball imagine if you could
every time
that a shot was released or in football
that aaron rodgers or jimmy garoppolo
jimmy garoppolo throws
an interception every second has but
let's say every time steph curry shot
the basketball
you would immediately know whether the
shot went in as it was flying toward the
basket
would you would you watch a version of
basketball that had that probably not
that would take all the fun out of it
right
and i encourage people to do the same
thing try to look at the position of
your own eyes try to appreciate some of
the complexities
try to see you know if the shot goes in
or not that's where part of the fun lies
and people
struggle to find the truth it's not only
about
oh you know oh the computer said this
you know what a big mistake what a
blunder
it's about appreciating the search for
truth the
heart and the soul that these players
put in uh to try
to be as precise and as you know as
nuanced as possible in their play
for sure and i mean even this position i
see the bar saying plus 3.15 over there
that's not how the players are thinking
serrano is like i'm
losing but i don't see how i lose the
game and uh savion's thinking wait oh
shoot this knight's coming to f3 to
check
i have to be careful and so he's gotten
back his queen but
there are no weaknesses yeah black is
that material but no weakness in king e6
look at this everything is safe and
sound here
h4 i like he's playing
okay e3 not yet but i'm looking
for the right time for an ethernet move
i would go a4
and i would go 95 back to d3 or to g4
right
give me the g4 square for my knight now
with white you would consider taking on
d5 that's
whoa whoa whoa e3 now three so tempting
it is a four he's gone but okay three
zero
the pawn e3 e3
take it take d5 i think you have to do
it i'm just too scared of that bishop
wait a minute
91 oh
that's a nice move though queen eight to
take on e3 with the queen
this is not i mean it's probably still
winning but it's not easy
it has borderline fortress yeah it is
borderline fortress
and f4 is probably a very good move
because the g6 pawn is
going to be hurt if black loses that
deep on that's still not over in that
event of that you could it's how easy is
it to miss a fork here or something like
that
and actually if you do play f4 there's
the possibility that you can't make
progress in your pawns because you have
d5
d5 oh rook d5 was so nice there
and i might have been winning but this
this still might be a fortress
it's how do you make progress here
exactly you have to bring your king but
that's so dangerous you're playing with
fire
and you just can't push a pawn there's
no break
this is i think it's a fortress drop
this is a dream rook f7 rook f5
how are you going to stop me right the
king just cannot
penetrate sort of the fifth ring even if
it does
you're only asking for trouble i would
be careful with white hair about moves
and stuff like that
right there could be a timely knight f5
yeah in the g3 pawn
yeah lexi is just saying all right
you're not going to push me around here
no you're just going back and forth and
there's no way to make progress because
you can't go pawn h4 to h3
which is what you need to do yeah that's
exactly right it's all about the pawn
breaker you have to dislodge one of the
pieces now
yeah i've seen this idea of bringing the
king around to you know b4 but but
the rook extends its influence
throughout the whole board that's the
strength of a rook
exactly and just knight h6 knight
to uh g4 kingdom king g8 the thing is
black doesn't need to do anything
yeah there's no attempts even there's no
way to force zooxan there's simply
absolutely nothing
uh oh yeah king d5 broke out five is an
important note
you don't don't bring your knight f5
almost works right hit g3
rookie seven but not quite keeping the
rook on f5 is just sensible
i think it makes sense that that sam is
playing this out he's definitely
torturing
serrano he is making him find these
moves but
by and large i mean there is very little
to play for here oh
oh wait a minute why did he allow that
because he's got
oh my god but now if you go rook f7 i
will take on f7
right you have to be careful you don't
need to allow that it might still be a
draw
wow it's still a fortune oh fifty movers
oh that was all of my weight i think
we're in a draw
it puts 50 moves it's still a draw there
robert knight g4 yeah
there's just no way to make progress
yeah that was awesome
um you know we can just bring up the
previous game very quickly because uh
even though the queen got to e7 and the
kings on e6 you just go knight g4 knight
h6 and the best you have is some kind of
uh check and a king comes up so what a
way to end that game a 50-move
rule draw and we have a sharp game
once more there's an extra pawn on c4
for black but it takes a lot to keep it
and
white is ahead in development white is
pinning this knight and the sacrifice is
typical the knight is still pinned
take with the pawn here danya these type
of lines
are so so tricky and we saw this
was it yesterday or was it two days we
did see that yesterday yesterday
right we saw this uh variation with
queen v6 cast
queen side c5 so this is not actually
the batmanic uh they have wait it is
above nx
uh or um it's somewhere between a mosque
and above enoch usually
in the mainland bob and the bishop comes
to g2 right that's why i was just
uh dragging bishop over there so it's
different and
we can highlight some of those
differences in the sense that
you often play c5 as black in the
budvinic because you're trading bishops
on g2
and exposing the light squares around
the white king but because you haven't
played g3
your light squares are better defended
here from white's perspective
and the queen dropped back to c7 the
palmer's on the a6
c5 now not so easy with the b5 pawn to
attack
this is a modern chest at its finest how
could you explain this in
20 seconds to people i would say black's
king
is safe for the time being but in order
to gain activity
you have to make move like c5 at some
point and that makes the king worse
especially with bishop f3 and trading on
the light squares
and for white you right now have a
board state where you are up one pawn
but the pawns are all over the place and
black has potential
aiming at the d4 pawn and potentially
later pushing pawns on the queen side so
the pawn a6 in the end game could be
overextended dania i have no idea how to
evaluate this position
no this is crazy and the way i like to
explain these positions sometimes is
through the lens of a
concept in physics which is potential in
kinetic energy
you know when you're going down the hill
on a roller coaster you've got a lot of
kinetic energy that's white
white is moving his pawns around you
know he's he's making improvements to
his position he's inducing weaknesses
it may look like black's very passive
but he's got a lot of potential energy
when the position uncoils
if white is not prepared for that there
might be hell to pay something like
knight e5 you can see
how all of black's pieces again they
look like they're pushed back
back against the wall but one or two
files open
and white's position can collapse like a
house of cards
totally true and right now you have to
consider b4 it's considered 95 so the
position is quite complex
and that's why 7n is in the think tank
b4
always an option right that is just the
move you consider but then you look at
the c4 pawn wait that just weakened my
pawn
unnecessarily what are the tactics in
this position
it's really difficult to figure it out
because the individual moves both
players are seeing them
but it's not about the next move it's
about four moves down the line like if
you play v4
it does that allow the c4 pawn to drop
or do i have to never queen takes a6
pinning this knight
protecting c4 but then c4 pawn is pinned
right like you just think about this
going forward do i have b3 here
everything is getting crazy yeah there's
more traffic than
rush hour and san francisco here i mean
there's everything is going on
and this is actually happening queen
decent size away from that pawn on a6
didn't want to open up the rook is what
i gather yeah
clearly this is equal zero zero zero
yeah obviously uh
of course mr barr um
hmm what does white even do how do you
even think about what to do here because
if you go d
e which he does you open up that a a
bishop but you could not allow black to
form that on phalanx
right but g2 is hanging because you have
a castle
maybe oh and then c3 for black
potentially
you have to use vc but i was gonna pin
that knife that was the idea
no i i'm with you there i think that
it's certainly valid and
actually might just be a good move but
there are some counter shots very
quickly
for black as well so it's not so
straightforward
and castling queen side as mentioned you
know there's c3
as uh potentially this bishop takes g2
your knight and a4 isn't exactly the
happiest piece who made bishop c6
to defend the knight and trap the
opposing knight
all these are possibilities here yeah i
mean the
it seems after castles that the
evaluation general
uh graham has to build bars filed a
lawsuit against the move castles long
i was going to bring that in and did
that in an awkward way we need three
instead okay so queen trade i mean an
endgame is robert is just as complicated
as the middle game here
right and you know there's these
asymmetrical pawn structure where white
has more upon the king side black has
these pawns on the queen side are they
strengths are the weaknesses the pawn c4
could fall very quickly so what moves
would i consider for black at this point
i guess bishop d5 comes to mind maybe
bishop takes g2
as well do i trade on e3 or allow the
capture on e6 i don't think i allowed
no that pawn on f6 becomes so strong
right
and now you can go to f7 if you uh end
up trading any city you sleep on it yeah
i mean this is just
you rely so heavily on your intuition
here
if you're a human i mean this is if i
had to envision
how magnus carlsen let's say trains with
his coach
this is what i imagine like he solves
positions like these you know he gets
two hours to think about
the best move for white um and actually
training in these types of chaotic
positions
is one of those sort of russian training
methods i think mark varetsky advocated
for that it really builds your
intuition i mean calculation wise it's
impossible to be precise
but what you learn are these sort of
cues that you can use to sort of make
heads or tails
of these very chaotic positions but i'm
completely failing in that regard right
now
i still don't know what's going on yeah
this is a
wild position and sevien down on the
clock down on the scoreboard he
really wants to get this game but after
knight takes c5 it does look like that
black king is in more danger than
white's king even though white's king is
uncastled
that could be a good thing because you
don't know where the checkmate's coming
from
not really the clearest of attacks
coming your way and knight b7 is weirdly
a move
yeah i'm considering shutting down your
bishop on
a8 and also opening my queen to your a7
pawn
yeah just feeling like black's king is
going to be some trouble he does
precisely that now queen takes g2
is that a move it certainly is it's
worth considering
and after queen g2 there could be some
kind of queen h3 check if you need to
trade the queens i don't want to trade
queens necessarily
but if i need to and i can also just
play rook to f1 slide my rook to safety
knight's under attack a7 is under attack
a lot to
calculate absolutely no i agree i have i
think we share the feeling here
that white seems to be slowly but surely
getting the upper hand here uh
initiative wise
now rook f1 i was thinking about b3 but
then if you take on da the king
has well maybe b3 because if if knight
takes d then bishop before check
aha you're trying to just go for a quick
checkmate but after b3 there may be some
rook a4 move which not only
stops bishop b4 but attacks for c4 pawn
it is getting just
so intense right now he plays rook f1
and b3
certainly a possibility here and there
it goes the ambulance i don't know if
you can hear the sirens but
i don't know if they're coming for
white's king or from blacks exactly
man robert we're on the same page way
too much today
i'm worried about me not about you in
this situation i'm worried about you not
about me so
uh now b3 rook a4 what if you throw in a
bishop b4 check and you go rookie 8
no that definitely does work a knight d3
check i mean
it could work i love sacrificing other
people's pieces
you learn well because i've been doing
it for years and that
is something that you want to accomplish
bringing your rook to e8 and b3 does
help with a very concrete threat of
bishop before
not just check but checkmate just to
show that on the board quickly
after b through like queen e5 here comes
bishop b4 the king is stuck in the
center
and you're just in big trouble another
one of those ideas there are
instances where rook takes h4 has to be
considered
rookie rookie played he does set up that
discovery
queen takes a seven is the most tempting
move what does he have planned against
that oh my lance there's an idea
there are many different ideas there
we're trying to like
you're trying to stack your queen on f1
at some point and then a perpetual with
knight t4 knight f3 so
beautiful we've got to show you wait no
but 297 guards d4
oh my gosh we both were going for the
same mechanism it doesn't work we'll
show them the analysis
heroes knight f3 check king d1 queen f1
we're looking at rookie one and knight
d4 back to f3
because the king has to go back and
forth from d2 to c2 but we forgot the
queen could backtrack
and take on d4 because otherwise this
would just be a repetition but the queen
takes the knight and then
white wins he's running out of time and
he goes b3 he simply ignores the threat
on the a bishop preparing bishop before
but what if serrano just mops up
a8 and then e8 up bishop before wins
white's queen look at that rook on h8 it
mobilizes exactly the right moments
yeah this is pretty crazy castles
can watch this castle oh my gosh casting
like
inside here that just might be a crusher
he did it he doesn't i forgot the king
could move
because he's been there so long but i
remember now i would not take the bishop
i would just go something like f3
oh to get the queen away from the
defense of the king over here
i would this is where you find some sort
of a crush you do not just take the
bishop i guess you
can can you play also like rook fte1
threatening some kind of bishop g4
check with amazing i don't think it
really works out but i'm just looking at
all the tactical possibilities in a
position like this
yeah and f4 is also possible by the way
mm-hmm
this bishop remains underrated okay oh
okay so he turns
i mean this makes sense bishop c4 rook
c8 though has to be reckoned with
true there's rook d4 i guess that uh
um and what's white
one pawn for the time being with f7 and
b3 probably are just
falling this is winning king b1 game one
is bishop d5 check if the knight came
back oh that's exactly what we should do
oh he misses it he missed the check rook
d2 though
knight e3 but then takes an and and oh
careful anesthesiologist me oh my 92 8
would be mate you're right
oh my goodness covers the d2 square
we saw in anastasia's mate possibility
yesterday in that match knight of one
back
okay i thought you'd go for the trick
serrano's he's not showing
okay well i guess this is completely
winning yeah take on f7 and
there should be six okay not finding the
bishop he's the four the bishop works
something about them he doesn't like
yeah i guess it's just hard to recognize
in certain positions
yeah f7 bishop oh bishop
boom goes the dynamite and
black remains only with a king and a
bishop
what a game robber what a game oh
my gosh and they're out of time i wasn't
even looking at the
match and neither were they
well we do have the five minute portion
in the books it is a five to three lead
for alexei sarana and donna does that
surprise you at all because
sebian according to smart chess
predictions was the slight favorite in
the five minute portion
but serrano he looked sharp under the
duress of time trouble
he did and i think what lexi was able to
do is find that medium
he was a little bit sloppy at the start
of the match but so practically strong
he found ways to complicate the
situation in sevien's time trouble and
then robert toward the end of the match
i think he started apportioning his time
very very well all
led up to that final game absolutely
incredible complications which
both of them handled so expertly but
sarah now with moves like
queen takes a seven castles long the
ability to find these tactical blows
quickly
he jumps out to a two-point lead so ball
squarely in samuel savion's court but
everything left to be decided here the
fight is still ahead
absolutely and we may need a year to
figure out what was going on in the game
and we also need some time to recover
because
our brains were just all over the place
we are going to take a quick break and
when we return
we'll be back for the three minute plus
one second increment portion of this
junior speech his championship match
between sam sebian and alexis serrano
you will not want to miss the action
brought to you by chess.comchestkid.com
we'll be back shortly
[Music]
so
and we are back ready for the three
minute plus one second increment time
patrol of this matchup between samuel
sevian and alexei saranac
daniel we had an excellent start to this
match a 5-3 lead
at the moment for sarana if you were
coaching
sevien what would you tell him how can
he mount a comeback
in this match that was indeed an
incredible five-minute segment
and as i often say it's it's important
to put things in perspective
uh and to realize for savion that the
games were close it was better
much better for example in the first
game i don't think he needs to make any
global
opening changes i do think that moscow
variation he's entering
with black um maybe he did a little bit
of work there
uh perhaps he will go for the standard
bobbinic variation
so that's one thing i think he needs to
think about in terms of the time
management uh
in some of the critical moments robert i
think maybe he hesitated
a little bit too much in terms of
calling some of alexis bluffs
so that's basically what i would tell
them maybe a little bit more confident
in terms of the critical moments but by
and large
it was close and the three-minute
segment can go either way it was so well
played by both of them and again we see
the opening
that they started the five-minute
segment with this english with knight
before
yeah i'm a little tired of this opening
to be honest i wish we could get
something new but we do have a
difference because that knight was
coming to a4 with the queen still on d1
and some of the other lines now the rook
is on d1 and that
should be helpful for white but look at
sauron he's closing the center
putting his pawns in a chain here the
problem is you can't develop this bishop
without dropping the b7 pawn
yeah so cd and bishop f4 is a very
standard way to develop and
you stop the rook from coming to b8 so
trouble could land very quickly after
rooksy won an ip5 there
um yeah he goes bishop f4 immediately so
saranac has to solve this problem
asap and this upon e4 it looks good it's
blunting the bishop on g2
but it also is a pawn that requires
defense by another pawn so d
takes c4 it will help black to some
extent but it may just cause too many
difficulties
on the e4 for instance dc queens queen
c4
e4 is under attack and if you play
bishop f5 i may even be able to play d5
just blasting through the center and
putting another attacker on the e4 pawn
right and this is definitely a critical
moment
uh and and so not trying to find a way
to untangle his pieces
the move b6 comes to mind but it doesn't
resolve the weaknesses on the queen side
i mean white could take on d5 and go
knight p5 he goes for queen b6
interesting
and now there's always that question do
i take or do i leave it because
queen takes b6 will double and isolate
those pawns over here once you take
on d5 but you see some trades happen and
maybe it's not the most that white can
get from the situation so
uh whether i allow the doubling of my
own pawns remains to be seen by taking
on d5 right away because cd
you don't have time to take back on d5
because cd5
knight d5 if you take on b3 thank you
for the inter mezzo that's a check
to your king and then i take back the
queen and i win a piece so
if i take on d5 black has to throw in
queen six b3
in which case white gets this semi-open
file whether that's enough
for an advantage that's another story
yeah
and uh the move c5 i think you should
refrain from because the queen would
have just dropped back and the pressure
on d5 would have been lifted he does go
for this knight b5
i mean it certainly seems unpleasant for
black i i would not want to be in
saranac's position i think accuracy is
required knight c7
you can make it draw if you want knight
b5 knight c7 is or was i should say at
this point in draw good call
and it still is so if you want to make a
draw just go back and forth but white is
better here there's no reason to do this
rook d to c1 i think it's what you just
said
uh it looks good for white because the
knight isn't getting trapped it's well
defended here
and it can still retreat to b5 at any
moment
with this back and forth yeah i mean you
could always repeat once
um but bishop g4 yeah i thought about
this and now
you could choose between you could go f3
and try to cut into that pawn wedge
but that's not that that's not necessary
i mean you could also go with e3 and
it's not like the knight on c7 is going
to get trapped in fact it's white's
greatest asset
yeah so he goes king f1 i like that move
i think the
non-committal approach with e3 yeah
there could be some problems in the
light squared later in the game
and there's some h3 ideas here yeah i
need to be careful of this bishop
on g4 uh i'm just going to push that
back
it does that and g4 okay i like that
now okay 5 comes to mind also oh but
then there should be four maybe
or bishop d8 you have to be a yeah a
little careful there
this is an important moment and okay
again
i probably can go knight b5 and evacuate
his knight
right but he knows f3 he's claiming he
can do that at any time because the rook
on a7 can't move and it can't be
defended so
well not anymore will be a possibility
oh
nice but i'm sure he sees that he's
weighed the calculus of it and that's
what savvy
that's what sarnot uses king f2 now
reinforces the threat of knight before
knight takes a6
exactly wasn't available before because
the check and there's also bishop f1
improving the bishop from its current
space which is not doing much of
anything
then rerouting that to f1 to put
pressure on the pawn but also the light
squares because if black plays a5
thank you so much for the b5 square
right and if you try to go bishop d3
that bishop is not going to remain there
now bishop
well rook c6 this this looks like
complete and total
domination on the queen side
um too many areas to draw yeah i mean
knight b5 now is just
open for business and wow he's lighting
up that queen side look at this
i mean i just can't even keep a pleasant
looking face
i'm getting squeezed even though i'm
just watching this game
yeah these kinds of binds now it one has
to be clear
it's not like he's going after a
particular pawn i think he's just going
after black's pieces
at some point rook c8 rook c6 96
so this is almost impossible to play i
would move the king away if i were black
and sort of just try to survive as long
as possible
see if if perhaps sevien places a piece
on a sloppy square allow some sort of a
tactic so
i wouldn't say it's over but um if he
plays this accurately white should be
winning
yeah just really difficult for black to
come moves you say king h7 a possibility
he was bishop a6 to attack this rook
b8 he said rook b8 goes after the b6
keeps the
pin alive there's also knight takes f7
ideas let's say rook b8 oh because rook
c6 the rook b8
king h7 there may have been knight takes
f7 because i'm distracting your rook
from the
bishop on d8 so catch he goes rook c6
instead
saying you can't attack my rook my
knight covers b7 it covers b5 i'll take
your bishop no matter where it goes
oh man just gaining more space but
should be i would go back to d3 now
though you got to be a little bit
careful about that e4square that's what
he does
what can i just take on no bishop f6 for
like king e3 and taking on d5
you could go eat king e3 right away yeah
why would i take an f6 when i can just
do this right yeah
bishop before perhaps black should try
to liquidate but you're going to not
only lose a pawn but the pressure is
going to remain
so it's not like you lose a pawn so you
lose the pawn and it's still very bad
right and look at this rook d6 move
trading off a pair of rooks
i think that's a great choice yeah i was
a little bit skeptical because of bishop
f6 but now i look at it in bishop e5 and
that pawn is fast and it's over
yeah rook c2 just the safe and sound
method
and d5 is coming king c6 c7 d6
etc yeah i mean this is there's some
precision required but
like i said at the start of the batch
robert i i'm thoroughly impressed with
the technique
uh by and large not of course the
resilience and the resourcefulness goes
without saying but the technique also uh
is
reminiscent of someone very very
experienced uh
and uh here we see just d6 the red
carpet has been unrolled now you
intercept the bishop on h4 no f5
very precise yeah i was actually
thinking about f5 move a little while
ago
he plays it and he only has to watch out
for his b2 pawn that's
the one thing that seven has to look out
for but here he gets d7
and once the trade happens here comes
his queen resignation
that was a fantastic positional effort
by sam oh do you see sam
you see him just like nodding his head
he's getting himself into that
he's pumped right now wow and but now
has not moved i feel like sorry now is
just hanging
he's like oh we'll get this opening once
again i lost one game in this line but
uh it's tactical
vigorous that is a head workout right
there those are some
vigorous nods by grandmaster sevien
for sure and well speaking of vigorous
look at this line that we see once again
super duper
sharp the bishop on f4 is hanging and
this time seven throws and bishop takes
c3
before doing anything about this bishop
on f4 so the bishop for
white stays alive and the bishop for
black
has captured on c3 right what i always
wonder robert is do they look up these
lines in the break i think
probably there's different approaches
some players feverishly go onto their
chest space look at files file saws
some just you know down an espresso and
close their eyes for a couple minutes
something tells me that um these players
are doing more of the former because
this is a very theoretical heavy
uh match um i you know i wonder whether
they in fact did that what do you think
robert
i think they did they just probably
looked up one or two lines because you
can't do
everything in a seven minute break or
however long they have
so you just quickly just look in line i
haven't enjoyed the position i've been
getting
from the black side of this opening let
me go check
just a couple lines and yeah here
there's no
real mating attack that i'm seeing
and the queens have just come off the
board g5 is falling and that's probably
bothering sebian but it is even material
opposite-colored bishops the one thing
dania i'm sure you're going to highlight
this as well
this bishop coming to f6 at some point
could be a big nuisance
i think that this bishop coming to f6
could be a really big nuisance
um robert stop copying what i'm saying
you keep repeating everything i'm saying
it's ridiculous you know it's telepathy
at this point
yeah and i think that again this is the
one thing that surprises me somewhat is
the speed with which
sardar goes into these lines uh in the
e4 and himself but he's not getting that
much i mean
at best maybe his position is
symbolically for choice but even that i
doubt
because there might be a bunch of
exchanges down the e file and just a
draw
and we see the nitrate being offered and
seven goes i respectfully decline let me
point on a4 to get after your c3 pawn
and it's just an important little mini
lesson here if you take here he's
probably concerned this bishop coming to
f6
the d5 pawn being the target and even
though there's no immediate
checkmating net that black has to worry
about it just feels
like you have a slightly worse position
and that's probably why he went for the
activity
rather than just swapping knights and
the bishop on d7 will not have the same
strength
that a bishop on d4 does yeah the move
rook c1 if you have to make a move like
that that means
things are not necessarily going
particularly well i mean i don't think
it's disastrous but the more i look at
this position robert initially i thought
yeah that bishop is really good on d4
uh you know mating threats but if sebian
is careful
that weakness of the pawn on c3 that's
more of a static weakness and that's
something that's going to saddle white
for
essentially the rest of the game unless
he finds a way to somehow
train it off i'm with you and
you know what next the bishop 24 looks
good but you can't just claim
i have a good bishop now my position's
all great
in fact black as you're saying has in a
quick
threat he takes the pawn against c3
directly
and bishop a force should be three
yep watch out for 92 at the end of that
variation where you take on b3 and
knight two so the rook
needs to stay protecting the square the
king came out
two knight a2 another free pawn no i
guess he wants knight d2 and what he's
banking on is this
again the possibility of matrix and the
bishop covers the square on e8
but okay so let's see what happens
knight b5
bishop f6 i don't like this for black
anymore yeah
i don't like them a bishop takes v3 at
all because now the bishop dominates the
knight now black is paralyzed he's tied
down to the eighth ranked rubber
oh it's the best don't play d4 was
rookie forward cage four that could be
made this way was that just winning
uh it looked pretty strong that was a
great catch
savion is still nodding i would not be
nodding here if i were black
i think he's trying to pump himself up
rather than actually thinking that he's
doing well yeah but he's got 30 seconds
and he's
and he's worse and things have gone why
does serrano have two minutes and seven
seconds
i don't understand it's crazy this guy
this guy's a madman
so he goes rook to d5 ending the knight
don't go c5
no rook c5 would allow the back rank
mates he's bringing the knight to e6 it
seems like
cold blooded defense now by sam i do
like what he's doing quite a bit rook c2
is possible now and rook g2 even ideas
oh look at that stopping f4 rook h3 or
h4 h5 trying to get the outside pass
pawn this is fantastic defense by by
sevi
getting the knight to e6 but h4 now
being prepared by sarah now this is
still
complicated it might end in a draw right
but it's not so easy to play with 20
seconds left to your opponent's v55 so i
would start pushing the pawns on the
queen side
i mean both f4 f4 is very dangerous now
because you can't take there's rook d a
checkmate do not play very 57
in every c3 attack begins
it does f5 comes then where's the knight
going to c5 and the efficient g5
watch out for bishop g5 bishop h6 oh you
oh
you too careful watch out that way five
changes i wouldn't go rooksy three wait
qg five vote h3 and then rookie chase me
or rook c3 also
ah is there no defense no defense wow
simply nothing that they do look at that
bishop dominating everything
too good yeah oh that's that's a sad
move to play
yeah sag and rook c7
okay doesn't win the a7 which you could
have done before
go king g6 okay rookie three check king
of seven and rook c3 and get this rook
in c file
yeah the knight is just completely just
not capable of guarding everything
and he's gonna go a5 once the rook comes
to eight so he's not losing his pawn for
now
excuse me um wait a minute rook c4 would
be a nice move here
oh my gosh if he plays rook c4 that's
even now rook c4 i mean there's nothing
to calculate the pawn race isn't even
close
i would do it i mean he's got a minute
in 20 seconds yeah but you're a
ridiculous human being so rook c4
he's going to play it i know elections
but knight takes on e5 yeah yeah and g5
it's just very direct okay fair enough
fair enough
yeah only a psychopath like me with play
rooks before
i wasn't going that far i was just well
saying that it was an
unnecessary tactical sequence that still
was very good
thank you all right i'll take that as a
compliment so check f6 came over
i agree that it was unnecessary but
begrudgingly and uh a win there for for
sarnath that is a
definitely a setback for sam who i felt
like robert and correct me if i'm wrong
was confident he got out of the opening
with a good
end game and just things misfired a
little bit there again the time
management
serrano is getting away with with
playing very fast and here we have
an old school rook g1 that was a line
put into practice by vasily vanciuk
i think in the 90s and we have a
sicilian so we have an e4
so it is sevien who decides to change
his
first move and that last game we had
highlighted the bishop
on the dark squares that's what it all
came down to and that is why
sauron won that game so for sevien he
was fine
he was doing well but the long term
pressure
got to him and it was sarna who took
that game yeah this one
the rook g1 punji iv where is your
attack coming from exactly you push the
pawn
that's all good and fun what
next another bishop on f3 we saw one on
f6
now there's one on f3 i didn't like e4
right
just keep that bishop this line is both
positional and tactical yeah
i was going to say we often see end
games and what white is going for here
is the sort of how do i even phrase it
there's a bunch of these semi-weak
squares that black has on b6
uh white's got the initiative but if
black can resolve the immediate problems
obviously white has taken certain
liberties on the king's side and created
weaknesses of his own
wow the point here is like bishop bishop
h3
so if i go bishop here you're rook d7 i
bishop h3 attacking your
if it drops his bishop to e6 you can
just trade on d8
the knight can't take back because the
e5 pawn falls the bishop can't take back
because the knight d6 check knight takes
b7 so the king had to take
and i would even consider f4 here for
what bishop g2 can't be played because
the knight's hanging just
you know the movie like i mean it can be
played it which is one of the night i
think
yeah it is impossible to do that just
don't recommend it
yeah just want to make it very very
quick accurate okay so
f4 played wow following the advice of
one grandmaster
uh we all make mistakes every now and
then but the point is just to open the
position up
uh the king is in the center for black
not the end of the world without queens
on the board
but not e5's under threat if you take me
on f4 i take with the bishop my
bishop one f4 looks very strong there
yeah you can still get checkmated rook
t3 king c8 knight b6 there i mean it's
it's
yes and that happens obviously rook d3
will be met with king e8
okay so he covers the b6 square entirely
which i like
yeah it's hard to say who's better here
i mean it it's even hard to say who has
the initiative really
i like white's position because i also
think that the queen side pawns will be
easier to
push at some point and 96 is going not
just for
the long term but immediately this b7
pawn
if they take me on d6 i'll take back and
give me the bishop pair
right i mean it's it's also the one
thing is that white has advanced his
king side pawns very far
which does make it easy for black to
create a pass pawn right he can just
play f5
but obviously that is not significant
with so many pieces on the board it's
just like
in the event of a total liquidation upon
end game it's hard to say who that would
favor it might be black so i think
sevien ha maybe c4 c5 he's got to keep
an eye on the possibility of liquidation
and evaluated carefully and for sarina
he's looking at g6 h6 at some point as
well trying to open up
uh the king side his rook on h8 isn't
doing so much
and i would look to play h6 but for now
h6 there's just g takes h6 and there's a
problem
uh down that side right so rook d8 by
alexi chasing that bishop away
and um i guess after bishop a3 yeah i do
like
i mean i like the two bishops especially
in an open board like this
uh things are you know so nice to play
actively here in order to compensate for
that and um
we'll just quickly show also the current
odds we all like the
bobbing heads here and it's been sort of
zigzagging
sine wave kind of thing back and forth
which reflects uh
you know how close this match is yeah
and it's really cool because it's
brought to us by chess goals.com so if
you feel stuck at your rating you can
use
the innovative 12-week data-driven
premium study plan and that can help
benefit your chess there is a
25 off using the code jscc there's a
command for it so
you know get involved enjoy it it's a
great product
and brought to us by chess goals awesome
and by the way saranac at the 62
odds right now it's uh gone well for him
thus far but this game
is it going well from or after bishop g4
if you take it might taking with the h
pawn
and then going rook h3 and trying to get
your h7 bomb
yeah i'm a little concerned about knight
before
um because if you put a rook on well i
guess you could play rook c3 check and
then you could
shift your king to the b file you just
don't want to go a3 and blunder knight
a2 check
yeah so that happens so your points of
rook c3 there is knight a2 but not yet
because it's
check and so you don't have to move your
king away
right can you play can i play a3
because you can't take with your knight
there's rook c3
is good and if rook takes then the
knight is pinned to the rook the knight
is attacked so
oh now maybe knight d5 should be played
by sarnath
right but it's clear that he wasn't
moving he's not here to go knight to d5
because he's thinking right now
yeah he he acquiesces but
rook d3 maybe so you're getting
the bishop on f6 was under attack so
yeah oh yeah that's right i missed that
drops it first now bishop e6 fe-6 does
that give black a passed pawn
or an isolated pawn the answer is both
but how do you
assess this transition yeah which one
which one is it
that depends on how the game goes what
is going to be its defining
characteristic
c4 makes some sense here but you want to
be careful about pushing pawns here as
we talked about
and create weaknesses that knight is
very jumpy it can sort of chisel its way
in sideways position
king b2 instead i'm beginning to like
black's position here
yeah i am as well and e5 was played if
c4 there are knight f4 ideas
where my next actually go to h5 winning
your piece
and there's the d3 square that i'm
looking at you have to be very careful
here
if you are um sebi and actually rook
it's a rookie three i just take on g5 e5
is immune to capture
because it forks on the d3 right and
here comes the king
oh gosh cementing everything
yeah i think e6 this is not looking good
because white has not gotten off the
ground
on the queen side that pawn is passed
right now it's not isolated
i'm with you and g5 is falling knight
before check follow rook takes g5
i guess bishop e5 there but that's
winning oh
oh what a move what a tactic
but wait a minute i wouldn't be so sure
i don't have a minute to wait i see 15
seconds left
and less for the players that's right
wait wait 10 seconds here
so before he's trying to calculate do i
allow the capture do i take here but if
i take those king takes and the king
comes up
right but 95. oh 95 i would have cut the
bishop
off but then king before but now 95 c5
checks see that doesn't work anymore
okay king d5 is going to be at times
gonna move seven
here comes c67 there's a thing
simultaneously
and then where's the but where's the
black king go at the end of this oh
bishop
of course this is losing oh my god
losing on time and position
and seven he is just did you see that he
breathed
a sigh of relief and he grabs a swig of
his water
he's ready for the next game we have
another queen to nimzo
wow and sarina i mean he is a
level-headed guy but we could just tell
he was
rattled that was an incredible turn of
events and when you get into those minor
peace end games and i just want to say
one thing
um and i have to give credit here to my
good friend
peter gionato's video master of the
charlotte chess center
he noticed this when a player during a
match takes a
drink of water it usually means that
they're comfortable with their position
okay you never get take whatever drink
you have next to you never take a drink
of that if your position is bad it's
only when your position is good
and here we see seven digging into that
water that was an incredible game
well his position was good because the
game was over but until that moment he
wasn't taking any drinks
and he can breathe a quick sigh of
relief but the action continues
we have sarina on the white side of this
position we did see him eventually
win this game in this from this position
where the queens were traded though
on the g6 square so this time the queen
is on d2
no queen trades going right after the g5
pawn and i
actually do not like the opening choice
from sevien we've seen this time and
time again
it doesn't feel like he's getting the
types of positions that he is
super at home in and especially with the
queen's remaining on the board donya
it feels like black's king is in far
worse shape than white's king is
at least without a doubt um so i feel
like
my assessment of this line is sort of
swinging back and forth
i can't tell if i can't tell if if i
approve of this choice for white i feel
like one game it goes that way one game
it goes this way it's hard to say
oh so c5 knight whoa bishop
how would he see that so quickly that's
crazy
that's a counter-attacking move seven
saw that
instantly that's hilarious oh my gosh
right like we have rook d1 rook c8 and
both bishops are in trouble here
uh we're just going to take a step back
bring up the analysis board so we can
show you some of these lines here and
the problem for
for black is that if you move the rook
to attack the bishop
i take your bishop and attack your queen
in the process so you have to find this
with bishop d3
and he trades on f8 so we are getting
into a position with
a series of exchanges and white
is even in material but has an extra
pawn
in front of the king so dania when you
look at this is h4 a huge threat for
white because if we just go back a
second that's beautiful
h4 queen h4 rook h1 would have trapped
this queen over here
right and that's why he goes queen f6 on
pinning himself i'm inclined to say
probably the position is about equal so
why does the weak pawn structure on
the queen side black has a very weak
pawn on g5 and you do not want to give
that pawn up because that would also
fork the king and the rook
i i think that it's going to fizzle out
uh into into a draw shortly
well one thing i'm considering is if we
do trade queens and i play the c4 move
right because there's a
pin on your rook if i'm thinking
long term in the king and pawn end games
do i have the potential to spring free
and outside pawn
for white but then i also have this side
of the board with a pass pawn from black
we have extra pawns and opposite flanks
and who is that favorite i like white's
position right now because of the
pawns in front of the king and the rook
on d4
pinning this pawn can apply more
pressure along the d file
yeah you could consider rook d6 to have
rook e6 in store against c4 i think that
i i do agree i think white's got the
blockade he's got the slightly safer
king
and rook t6 it follows but savion is
very good at
defending these types of positions and
not giving a lot of chances
uh so you know alexei trying what
what he can against c4 is not currently
a threat because of d takes c4
right that's a very important point c4
dc4 hits the queen and actually black
just wins in the spot so don't go about
and do that
and he plays a4 so just trying to
put his pawn on a square protected by
the rook it also stops any b5 ideas for
black if you're trying to stop
c4 and it's not so easy for either
player
to make moves because if you make a move
like king f6 for instance
is there a queen h7 no there's not but
you just have to keep an eye on it
and the same goes for white i mean if
you abandon your king queenie queenie
two could follow
so i think neither side is going to be
willing to take now queenie is an
interesting move if you take on d5
black is going to trade and then make
perpetual check with queen e2
exactly so everything comes off check
check back and forth
or if your king goes to h3 i've checked
on f1 you could go h4 though and then
after gh you could consider rook t5 but
i don't like it because a4 is also
hanging at the end of that
exactly and i think that we can tunnel
on that pawn or we can forget about it
but at some point it's going to be
relevant and
h4 is an interesting idea to follow up
with king to h3
and try to get the pawn back but with
the queen on e8 so strong eventually
coming to e1
you probably don't have it in you to
play h4
right queen e3 i guess rook d3
something like that but queen f4 so i'm
not sure what oh then rook takes d5
that's a funny little
sequence that is funny
rookie six now that is a pretty uh
that continuation signals to me that
savion is thinking about taking over the
initiative here
right his rook was passively defending
now it's on an open file
in front of the queen trying to
infiltrate so
what do you do here don do you think um
okay can you have two just to keep
everything close but can i swing to the
h file
you can but then i'll go back to g2 okay
so he takes oh i'll buckle up
queen d4 oh who's winning here
okay this is getting tricky because
that's queen two this is a rook h1 check
there is f6 rook takes g5
okay so i guess white has to bail out
well what about rookie five here
if i just shut your queen down oh okay
queen d3 played and
cute h6 rook d6 check the king has to go
back to g7 or
rook d6 f6 oh you sneaky sneaky guy
okay so rook d6 f6 takes kg7
is he gonna do it no he's not well
there's i think i could just move my
rook back
there too i i just might rook away so i
don't think it works out but we don't
have much time
okay we have the case going back and
forth and whoa
so we're going for a win so there's
check and queenie one
there must be some other things here
that uh for black that
can i mean the pawn a4 i said it was
irrelevant but maybe
now it's relevant i did mention there
would be a time that it would be
important
no that time has come because rook g5
king h6 there instead
i can't tell if they're repeating moves
or if one of the sides is making
progress
rookie five now rookie five mentioned
that move earlier he plays it and
there's queen e4 check
but then the king comes back to g7
[Music]
two seconds now all of a sudden serrano
slipped
really into two okay we're getting
kicked
no broke three rook f3 oh
you can take on a three and he does it
because it's a bailout and i think a
draw
or it looks like it should be but
nobody's going to probably player oh
okay he's gonna queen seven queen eight
double king of six let's create a check
i think white can actually if white can
win a seven
black is still going to have to give
perpetual right
and king g5 is very risky so he goes
quinn back to f6
good idea yeah drop
[Music]
now one of the sides could blunder here
and yeah it's always
b5 trade pawns king gets the b pawn king
gets the g pawn
that was all there was a lot of tension
there in that game
and it is just like by the way
sarina he's at 3k but just exactly
yep he's great that's a great place to
be that is a great place to be
and look at this set up by
sevian he brings his bishop snakes it
via d3 to c2
center is well protected here is knight
b4 we were talking about these
sort of spanish positions where you get
knight to b4
this looks kind of like it uh could have
come from the spanish but it's from a
sicilian
right we've got several of those
positions that kind of have the
overtones of our rai lopez
but but this is a good one for black i
think he's got the two bishops and he's
got the king's indian idea
we keep just referencing other openings
but he's got the king's indian idea of
going f5
yes uh you know f5 also knight f4
please take me on f4 i want to open up
my kingzinian like bishop
on g7 so here queen b8 it looks like a
set
well speaking of sad moves bishop c8
okay but is that a really
because a long range piece it can also
support f5
true and maybe even some potential on
the h3 square a sacrifice at the right
moment but
i didn't really feel good about seeing
bishop of c8
that's fair that d6 spawn is also
something to keep an eye on
right and i was looking at queen b8 and
rook f8 to c8
you know i'm making the rook look silly
on eight for the time being but
not that big a deal right hmm so what to
do now
bishop e3 just developing his bishop for
sure f5 is a double-sided coin that also
weakens
the position it's important to know
knight g5 is actually possible i think
at 496. ah nice looking you find an
attack
because f4 looks like it wins a piece
cutting off the bishop from the knight
but 96
takes politics it looks like you can
take a bishop on e3 but watch out for e7
with check and that would win the black
i would consider
f4 anyway and 96 just go queen f6
and then try to get f3 and even that if
that means sacrificing the exchange
which
way i will i would go f4 here
i could buy that he plays that force
nine h4 he also after
takes can play queen okay he did it but
queen he said i don't know about that
he still has your idea of f3 the e6 pawn
can be
attacked another time i bring the rook
in and knight d5 i can just take on e6
because knight d5 queen e6
97 check looks fancy because my queen is
pinned and under attack but king f7
saves the queen on e6 i do get away with
it
something about this though now even if
black plays
f3 though white can even go g4 and i
feel like black doesn't
quite have enough firepower to um
you know to make things happen when push
comes to shove now
queen takes c6 can be allowed in that
end game white has compensation number
oh yeah getting this knight to d5 and
the c file always
is compensation i don't know how
sufficient it is
but that is uh what i guess seven is
relying on also the b7 pawn can be
captured if the queen takes an e6
too early so it's not so easy here for
white or black to move i'd probably rook
a1 to c1
gearing up for the queen to capture on
e6 and trying to take control of the
open file
right and um yeah the time situation
it's so hard to play these positions in
a blitz game because
you can get easily kind of drawn into
the rabbit hole of trying to
understand the nuances of the position
which savion is currently doing he's
again a minute down on the clock and he
does go for knight q5 so let's see how
this unfolds okay
so using the queen as a block gator
knight c7 is a threat
watch out for the fork you go says look
for open file stopping it queen g4
i can take and bring my knight back to
f6 but i see what your point there's
knight e7
check but at the end of that knight
takes e4
okay none of that happens
rook d1 now very important to reinforce
the control it's not about the knight
it's about the control over the d5
square right it's the square
more than what piece is on as you're
saying but you do not want to take with
a pawn
right as that isolates your own pawn and
it will allow the e pawn to push it
well you do now but you know unless it's
a fork or something
of course so bishop f8 protecting d6 and
that's good news for the rook on c6 it
is free to
roam around the board but it feels like
a bind
as it doesn't actually seem like black
is up a pawn because the pawn d6 can't
go anywhere
right and we have in in some ways a
situation similar to the last game where
you know both sides are unwilling to
take the big risk
um and so this game might also just
peter out into a draw because neither
side is making progress but i think
saranat is making progress nobody
cancelled the idea of just attacking on
the king's side so
in many ways white's position optically
looks very appealing with that rook on
d5 but
if saranac can circumvent it and buy
himself time if he pushes the pawn
through to g4
things could get very unpleasant for
sebbian and the issue is
because seven is down a pawn and black
is
playing on both sides of the board right
now his queen on e2 stops g5 but now the
queen might need to protect the d5 rook
or if you take on
c5 here it is the the d-pawn became a c
pawn
and the bishop on e7 feels a little bit
better but the pawn e5 feels a bit worse
clearly now it's up upon black is
playing for a win white's got
pretty good drawing chances yeah the
pawn on e5 as he said weak but
we'll see he opens up the c5 square for
his bishop potentially there's also
ideas now still of going g5 g4 the
attack can actually be very strong in
these positions
right now as well as a possibility in
the near future
just planting the bishop not well no not
now the h5
would check what do you what does what
you though you can get checkmated in two
moves
oh yeah takes takes and then g3 check
and trying to yeah goodbye queen h6 and
f2 is hanging by the way
now what if bishop queen g4 queen c7
going after
f6 king f6 queen d8 check king g6
i see you trying to move around h4 he
plays it that's right
but there's got to be a back rank mating
oh my goodness g3
f3 and then queen h3 is there but why
does queen g5 check
and they take on h5 with check and then
yeah so
dinah's point is if you hit f3 you take
there's queen h3 mate but queen g5 check
i take on h5 will check i take another
check funny thing is if you play g3 and
f3 black is actually
threatening the move queen h3 yes
exactly to give up the queen from i was
thinking about that too before like if
you make some random move like
bishop e5 is queen h3 check takes in g2
and g1 equals queen
me let's get to the live position bishop
g3 check played
and the throat of queen g5 is
undoubtedly scaring yes
whoa okay i'm glad he didn't take on f3
that would have lost a piece so
he is stopping that at all costs i
really like that idea actually he didn't
throw in queen g5 check
and now he may be paying the price for
that right because the bishop
covers the square so is he getting
checkmated here
even queen d3 check might be a winning
end game or queen f3 takes the pawn with
check
yeah you're absolutely right look at
that pawn on h4 bishop d2
the king can't get in for black oh my
lands
the king can't get in so wait what about
king f6
well four who's winning no it's black
he won't be three so that probably was
wrong okay so the king comes around
and then d7 c6 v5 that's going to be
bishop
win the h4 pawn that seems good enough
it does outside passer
you got to make sure that white doesn't
close everything up but there's that b5
hole so the king
could actually head that way and the
pawn can head the other way and white's
resources will be
too extended right and black does not
want to be left with the h pawn does not
match the color of the bishop but
unfortunately for white you can't trade
off queenside pawns
your pawn's an a5 not in a square that
allows a tree
now the king is cut off there's just no
way that but okay this is just g3
so smart defending both pawns at the
same time now the king can just walk in
well but where exactly so i'll go
oh yeah you
way to say he's trying the other
direction but is that border close too
i don't think it is team jesus and
bishop g oh promotion and king f3 that's
nice
i think bishop g3 king f4 but you're
right he's gotta go for the promotion he
does
and it's still a game but it is king d3
there was more a little bit more precise
but this is also winning commission
yeah and the pawn end game is of course
winning the king is so much closer to
the pawns
yeah goodbye gobble gobble indeed
wow what a game so close savion put up a
great fight but
alexi with an iron fist there nerves of
steel and he delivers another victory
the lead still
stubbornly at two points
and he wants to keep his three thousand
plus rating that's what i was all about
sorry not three thousand seven seven
twenty nine forty three
no slouch either and we have a benoni so
the openings have been changing in the
quicker time patrol here
and what do you make of this decision
from seving to me it seems like he needs
he feels the urge to win so he's playing
a sharper opening
but has some real structural damage in
the form of this pawn d6
yeah i mean it's an opening that this
will either go very very well or very
badly i don't think this game will end
in a draw
um which is probably precisely why it
will and just
we notice here that the odds are you
know they're obviously they have
increased in sarena's favor but it's not
like
um smarter chess is predicting a blowout
there's a big
possibility you know this could turn in
one game and i think that's precisely
what
sam is trying to do he realizes okay the
three-minute portion is drawing to a
close
he wants to make that run before the
bullet he doesn't want to have to deal
with
a two-three-point lead going to the
bullet interesting
strategy we'll see if this gamble
backfires or whether it pays off
well based on the clock management thus
far it seems like it's it's not going so
well now sevien
he's taking on e5 with his pawn and look
at this
eight extreme the c5 i said a5 because i
was thinking of white playing a5
yeah a4 but this protected passer
on d5 the c5 pawn is a clear
target and even if it doesn't you know
win that pawn
it just doesn't feel good for black to
be stuck to its defense
right and 9896 is the classic plan
you're blockading the pawn
um but that doesn't tell the whole story
there's so many weaknesses in this
position that that actually might not
even help
um because white actually also okay so
he goes for a different strategy he goes
that h5
uh he's getting the knight potentially
to f4 black this is one of the good
things robert about the benoni and these
types of openings is
even when everything goes wrong because
of the nature of the opening and how
unbalanced it is
there's always going to be counter play
regardless of how
objectively bad the position is and it
looks pretty bad too
four eyes here because knight f4 i can
drop my bishop back to f1 so i don't i'm
not going to take that i don't want to
open up this bishop on g7
and it just feels like a bind and
eventually white can play g3 and kick
that knight but i really want to play
bishop f1
king h1 f3 bishop g1 i want to reroute
my bishop to a more useful looking
diagonal
this is there's just no i mean there is
a knight on f4 that looks nice but
you know you're not going to build a
build a kingdom around that knight
no and there's also a possibility for
white to take in like e5 at some moment
i don't think now is the time
because uh you're not ready to put more
pressure on the bishop e5
but the point is that you're potentially
walking into a pin
if you capture on e5 which you might be
ready for well now you're not ready for
it either as d6 that also has to be
considered in certain positions opening
up the diagonal
tarna i think is going for a plan where
he wants to push b4 i think he wants to
target
that and sebian realizing that
immediately goes for the threats here
queen back to g3
again saying no you aren't going to make
anything happen on the king side
and he actually might take with the pawn
on g3 queen g3 pawn takes your knight
has to go back to h5 and go g4
if your knight goes to f6 down goes e5
your knight comes back to f4
at some point i may have g3 trapping
your knight on the square
but 96 that is an idea that uh sarnath
has to pay attention to then i could
swing to d4
so i think we're gonna see rook b1 at
some point followed by b4
well 96 was almost a possibility
you need to watch out along the d5 if
this rook is ever hanging on d1
but that's why sarna he's put his king
on h1 no knight checks nothing like that
and here i okay so here's the plan
progress
bishop g1 then bishop f1 and you go
after the c1 you put a rook on c1
you move the queen away and then you
play f3 i know that's a very long plan
now he wants to chase the knight away
with g3
um you could consider d6 here because
well no i wouldn't go anything that
drastic but something where you go after
that seep on i think makes some sense
i'm i've been looking at that idea i'm
not sure i love the inclusion of the
pawn
h4 but he's saying that it won't
backfire i'm actually
safe on the king's side and
bishop e2 then he has to play f3 bishop
g1 at some point
yeah now f5 comes into play i agree with
you i think with that pawn on h4
um there's just enough uh tenderness on
the king side to where sevien can start
considering active counter play has
sarnot underestimated
these king side chances i think he has
things started to get a little bit tight
here
and the best thing that sevien is doing
is he's moving quickly in fact he's
keeping
pace with sarina and the bishop on h2
that looks like a great piece
if i say so myself they are amazing it
is controlling everything really it is
the
just the czar of the board here f5 it's
it's time
because now you can take with the pawn
on f5 as the 95 is no longer under
attack so it's a big difference
this knight can swing back to f6 if it
uh
has to and i'm starting to like black's
position
more although knight drops the f5 well
the bishop yeah
the only it is socially distancing
itself
right the only the only person uh who
might like that bishop is doctor anthony
but otherwise but it might not even be
about that bishop but i think it is 965
look at this
okay queen is under attack if this pawn
were on g2 i might recommend the queen
sack on the f8 but the pawn is on g3 so
the bishop's not hitting the e5 square
and if that's the case queen duck to b1
how about just uh
knight f6 retreat oh describe that g
pawn box and f6
is played and there's possibility if you
take on d7 queen d7 queen h3 you have to
be careful about the light squares
around the white king and here
it goes uh-oh the position is opened up
i think you're right on the money queen
h3 is a huge idea
e4 now the bishop opens up the bishop on
h2 robert
now alexi is paying a very serious price
for that bishop when the position was
closed i mean he didn't detect it and
here comes queen h3
you have to play queen f1 because
nigeria was such a big threat i wouldn't
trade queensland queen f5
knight then bishop d4 and the bish one
h2 clearly not a good piece absolutely
just the kitchen sink coming along the
file after knight for bishop d4 with 20
seconds on the clock now it's so hard to
play for white
does he give up the e4 pawn though i
think he does because
there's some kind of queen do you want
checks there's bishop before you have to
look
all across the board for the various
threats right after two yeah bishop d4
here we go
uh oh that's a problem that's h3
you know time this is eight seconds i
think it's mating
the gamble is looking like it's going to
pay off 470.
now you've got to be precise because
queen g8 mate comes into play in certain
positions queen g4 rook f2
bishop d4 still works no oh yes it does
yeah queen d4 queen b4 nice fine there
should be four is protected because i
can think about the queen
but wait a second rook f2 bishop d4 king
h1
i knew what you were going to say there
but this move king g2
that walks through h3 knight g4 back and
then there's f1 is made h2 is hanging
bishop d4 check is a threat too
many avenues and directions and threats
nice should i
queen g2 maybe but then bishop before
yeah okay immediately
and forward f1 is made yes it is rook f1
wow there's rookie two misplaced because
the bishop is cut off
and just he vacillated too much did
sarna i think he had to decisively act
on the queen side
amazing job though by sam to generate
counterplay detecting the moment
and pouncing mercilessly yeah he was
playing
very quickly which that's been a
struggle for him throughout this match
he's been down on the clock and he's had
much less time to figure out the
complications
in that game he was keeping pace with
sarina and then not only
capacity actually took a lead in the
clock and was starting to seize the
momentum on the board
here we have a position where 7 is white
there is this
little triangle here uh with the pawns
c6 d5 e6
and what do you make of this opening
because i don't know i don't really
mind it for either side yeah i mean it's
um
okay so dc is an interesting choice it
weakens both players pawn structure it
opens up that potential avenue of trade
on the the d file i think it's about
equal i mean i would take
probably white here because of the
disparity in the bishop placement
uh so i i don't know i mean you have to
decide what you take on c4 with first of
all
bishop takes seems a little bit more
natural to eliminate that tension but i
could see a case being made with for bc
because
later on white's bishop if you eliminate
the pressure on the c4 pawn
white's bishop could land on f3 and he
does exactly that again
though we see sir not jumping out to the
early lead on time
and actually not sure i like the
decision to keep queens on the board
for black you mentioned the c4 pawn and
if that gets defended the bishop can
leave e2
and it's easier to protect c4 with the
queens on the board it's easier to
protect the b2 bishop with the queens on
the board
and i just feel like with white having a
slight spatial edge thanks to this pawn
on c4
it could go very well a3 now will kick
the rook back
but that leaves the b3 square more
vulnerable to the touch and also the a3
pawn itself
it's going to be a bit more weak very
very true here and
uh i don't know how this should go but
i'm looking eventually for like a bishop
d3 but this is not
i mean i don't like well he wants i mean
bishop c3 is of course the threat but it
just seems a little bit too artificial
yeah queen a4 is what i'd play here
trade the queens off also queen takes a2
there's rook a1 that's another trap
but yeah a4 exactly 1a6 is hanging so he
couldn't even take on a2 i wasn't even
looking down there i figured that
it was immune to capture if uh savion is
giving up the pawn
like don't take it and now we're back
here
with a c4 pawn is still weak as i
mentioned the queen trait
should favor black b2 is something that
is harder to defend the c4 pawn as well
and there should be three is possible
here trying to liquidate and then take
on taking on b1 with the knight but
that's a move you play
if you're just shooting for equality and
you're trying to bail out
right because the end of it then the
black knight come to e4 the rook on the
b8 or d8
you pick a file of your choosing so it's
a way for
white to defend and he actually does
this good call danya
and i do think that black should be the
preferred side rook d8
is rook d one rupee
but i think that sarno has no problem
here whatsoever
right no i mean he he's he has the
choice here now one thing to
don't get the king to d6 here because of
c5 nice
that's a one way to blunders if it's a
check or don't play knight b6 because
knight b6 is still c5 there is
now c5 knight takes c5 defends the
bishop so
they see these things they eat these
things for breakfast i mean they do not
miss
these kinds of moves okay i don't want
to jinx them but
don't miss these kinds of moves and king
c5 is possible but king c3
knight b6 knight d2 so oh my god mate
yeah that's what i'm going for honestly
i'm trying to defend the pawn and go for
a checkmate
he plays c5 which i think is smarter and
yeah i was gonna say i was gonna show
that mate on the board because it's
funny
it is here knight v6 knight d2 94 is
checkmate maybe three also would win a
piece with c5 check
so that would be that's teenagers so
knight b6 would be a really good move is
what you're saying
it was just an excellent move in that
position for sure
okay so there is one thing that
obviously symbolically i think black is
the one with the pole because of his
pressure on c4 but
it is so insignificant because white has
allocated all of his resources and
actually don't laugh
but eventually if white reroutes his
knight to c3 via b1
and he goes a4 a5 potentially the move
knight b5 could be a little bit
unpleasant
i don't think any of this is gonna
happen i'm just saying black can't fall
asleep here either
certainly not and what black can do is
think about pushing some pawns in the
king side
but that also has risks in and of itself
because if you push your pawns they may
become more susceptible to being
attacked
and that's why sauron puts his bishop on
c6 covering that b5 squares please go
knight b5
win my pawn a7 i'll actually not gonna
lie that i'll take you
and then the it'll be a favorable
transition at least right
so they're maneuvering uh there is there
is some life
again okay that comes back to me
probably to d2 to just secure
everything a little bit more um solidly
is segment regretting that move h4 well
i don't think that sarnath has the
resources to make him regret it
yeah because you put two attackers in f3
it just quickly put two defenders there
okay
knight f6 knight h5 i like this g5
coming
okay i do think seven should have just
you know if it ain't broke don't fix it
i don't think you should have moved
anything on the king's side
and actually if you take on c6 does that
help white or black because the knight
versus bishop dynamic
can be hard to assess he instead allows
the knight to come right back to d2
tonight is
jumping around constantly and it's hard
to deal with with no time on the clock
true i didn't even look at the clock
savion once again down
a lot of time he's down a minute and
here we see g5 played
and is the king coming to e5 is the
knight coming e5 well now neither is
and g4 play watch out for this knight
come to h5 and knight f1 bishop g2
savion tries to net that in the bud but
knight
d4 that's a big square i guess it's a
fortress
you know who doesn't believe in
fortresses uh bishop f3
oh bishop three that's a sneaky move but
king b6 trying to go king a5
wow this knight shift can jump to a4
okay here comes the bishop oh oh king a5
knight b3 though i think that force is a
draw
right so the knights get traded then
there is a fortress because you can't
attack a
dark square palm with a white square
fish how do you even get to h5 you need
to get to g7 to get to h5 i don't think
there's a mathematical way to do that
amazing
that is i'm looking it's actually really
funny oh there no there literally isn't
a way to get to h5
no there's not you need to get the g7
which is v e8 but there's no way to get
to
what knight c6 knight b6 98 96 98 97 98
you get the point oh my god it's the
most epic plan of all time
watch him do it though he has all the
time in the world and at the end of that
white just plays knight f1 and offers a
draw
true but i hope he goes for it just to
show you that it is possible
right miracles i think he is i think
he's going to go for it and and at the
end of knight f1 they're going to make a
draw
yeah and there's no nothing that white
can backwards
because you have these pawns under
control you can't even attack
e6 ever right i mean this is always
you're you're kind of your hand is
shaking here it's unpleasant to defend
this
but if you just stay vigilant and there
he goes
well he's wait where is it going again
he needs to go to a8 to c7
to uh e8 to g7 hilarious
so yeah he needs to get this knight to
a8
bam so he'll have to play knight b8 d7
move the king over so that's like the
longest plan in the history of endgames
and it would just allow white to make an
immediate draw so it doesn't work
yeah and well he plays a5 okay that
doesn't actually do much
it gives you the a6 square so you can go
to e8
i think he's trying to lull sevien to
sleep and now he's going to
mount that maneuver mark my words he's
going to go night before night a6
he actually he does the night before so
excuse me those
words have been marked but now what do i
do with them
you i have a couple of things you can do
with them but i will not i will share
that
during the break
oh you're just the most polite
coconut immaculately polite
and we have another bononi sevien
probably has some fond memories
of the result of the last bononi but
likely not the position that he is
yeah nobody doesn't want to get that
allow saranac to have that pawn again on
d5 what do you think robert
well it's uh here comes bishop f4
looking like it increasingly now
one thing that i was taught a long time
ago if
maybe this is completely out of touch
with reality but if black has to put a
queen on e7 and the bononi
that usually means that well because the
possibility of e5 now is essentially
forcing black's hand so that is why
cevian acquiesced to knight e5 maybe
knight h5 and then knight e5
oh he does it again i can't believe it
but that was a really really bad
position yeah i don't enjoy this at all
and he spent time
to get the same position so i don't
think he trusts it either
when you spend 30 seconds your opponent
is moving just
instantly every single turn and then you
have the same position that we didn't
like
and bishop g4 so something about it
saranac didn't like either
but are you inviting f5 at some point oh
okay queen g5 watch out for your g2 oh
i think that what this is wait but ef
yeah what is this
now let me tell you one thing i think
that what sevien is doing is a conscious
psychological ploy he knows that the
position is bad he knows
what if sarnath fails to win this again
and it increasingly is looking like
black is recovering again
he is going to be particularly
frustrated so it's a gamble
but i think it just might pay off i'm
with you because right now i don't see
how white's pawns are moving forward and
i do see a potential for h5
queen h4 g5 g4 sounds like i mean
b5 it's like everywhere about all of a
sudden black is the one with an
advantage maybe white should just play
d6 knight d5 but i don't buy that either
that could just lose your d-pawn yeah
well it will i was just thinking of
putting that on d5 but that alone that
doesn't give
much right oh man
so what else can white do here queen to
e2 to attack a6 comes to mind because
you want to provoke a5
that seems to give me the b5 square i
won't complain about that
right i mean perhaps you yeah rook cto
is going to propose liberating
knight b1 knight a3 is an idea queen e2
would have been a big blunder just to
show that
oh nice it would have watched an f3 pin
here checkman g2
for hanging on d2 as well so don't
that question oh
f3 like in second and go rook f6
you can that's it probably not smart i
could go rook f6 and probably force the
queen
back to f3 right because rook f6 is pawn
f3 then you're giving up all the dark
squares
okay now no still probably not enough
what about queens for g5 g4 how are you
going to stop me mm-hmm
92 knights you won but then i go g4 when
your knight is on g1 it doesn't make it
to f3
yeah it doesn't look like it's good
enough yes knight needs to move up the
square to c4
right and the a6 pawn
is hanging over here so that's something
that uh you have to
keep some attention to if there's rook
to be a don't take on a6 there's pawn f3
that
right that's a vicious vicious little
tactic maybe there's also just go f3
f3 then you're inviting your eventually
that's true i was just gonna say you
take a gamble and you just try to go for
the queen side but no that's not going
to pay off
and i wonder if black's trying to go b5
himself
yeah he definitely is and the time is
the only thing in serrano's favor that
he can try to harness if he can make
this complicated
then his time advantage may make its
presence f3 is possible here because
that f2 pawn might fall okay so he does
that maneuver
i like it bringing the knight into f3
you called it and c4
is possible for black gaining some space
he does it even knight f3 here should be
considered yeah queen takes g2 no
because king g2 and then bishop e5 falls
at the end of the variation good thing
sam didn't pre-move something
expecting the queen to move we need
three now i would like invite the pawns
forward okay queen e2 also makes sense
stopping v4 and this queen can replace
the bishop and it's still a blockade
for black and this e4 pawn down here we
haven't highlighted that
you can play f3 as we've talked about in
other variations
but then the dark squares are still
under black's control despite the fact
that bishop was traded off
right and um okay so
again i think sir and i can take on e5
at
his leisure i think that he's wait now i
think that
sam has sort of underestimated this
maneuver over the knights f3 look at
this if rook v8
rook takes c4 has to be dealt with right
because the rook is hanging on v8
and this is precisely what i think we
noticed about the clock now seven has to
burn into his reserves
to deal with these threats he's under 30
seconds this has taken a turn
for the worse for black yeah because you
can just take on e5 and then take on c4
but the e4 pawn is hanging
at the end however this d-pawn is trying
to run so he plays queen c5
going right after the rook on b6 knight
takes e5's a thread he goes rook to v8
to protect everything including the b5
pawn
and this is just one of those positions
where it feels like white
should be better but proving it is
immensely difficult you try to play d6
wait
wait is b2 hanging it is but then d6 i
think
and then c3 like who's pawn i think he
blundered it but he's gonna pretend it's
a sacrifice
it turns out to probably not be so bad
no
i don't think it's great but i think if
e5 and maybe you sack on okay
oh i would be scared to play that movie
because c2
yeah what is going on here and there's
e5 e6 ideas the bishop is cut out from
the protection of the king on g7 but
knight d4
is also in the mix yeah e6 i would
consider and then just play knight t4
after that
yeah e6 looks pretty dangerous or knight
g5
because you just leave the rook on d5
because of the fork on e6
i think we're calculating it with
playing e6 and the d6 pawn becomes
weaker
knight five yeah the knight g5
queen d7 is like a desperate enemies of
queen c7 for white you just have to
consider all these possibilities and
rookie one okay he gives a check but
queen f6 what is his idea
yeah there's also c2 coming whoa and
they've broken d5s hangings that was a
terrible move i think
that was a really bad that was this
horrible move did we have
he had plenty of time on his plug yeah
that was not good
i don't have an explanation for that
queen no that was that was a
hallucination i think he thought the
king had to move and he saw something
got excited even if the king moved
though i mean black had c2 he walked
right into the
uh x-ray of the bishop and that was just
losing donna you missed it but
savion took a sip of water there no i'm
saying
the peter gionata's theorem
it has been mathematically proven to be
it has c2 oh yeah it's just wait
oh i thought there was some mating ideas
but no no king h6
there's no even knight f6 because i got
the h4 and he's four knight g5 pre-moved
forward age seven
yeah oh look at that he didn't even get
a queen so let me try
that so i get this queen here he's
saying no no no no no
no i don't see any of that this is just
that is a blow if sebian can take this
home
uh that is a big blow to end the
three-minute portion the lead
will still be at two points that is
exactly i believe where they started
no no it won't be it won't be two points
will be even
oh yeah sorry it's the other one
[Laughter]
yeah you know we're going to have a
thriller in the
stalemate oh that was close that was
close rook h8 check go for the
sacrificial
he sees it and he knows it and he is
very precise here serrano's trying for
stalemate but
hey kg4 just play king g4 you're
attacking the rook you're threading
bishop g3
resigns it is in deep tied robert we
kind of could sense it this was going to
be
the closest match yet guess what well it
has delivered that was some incredible
action in the three-minute portion
it certainly was and for sarina he's
probably quite frustrated with himself
because he had a lead
throughout this match and now it's tied
heading to the bullet where it's really
a toss-up because
even if one player is higher rated
unless it's a huge disparity like we saw
nihal sauron win yesterday against anton
smirnov it's
anybody's match at this point it is and
we will catch our breaths
and when we return 30 minutes of one
plus one buckle up
we'll be back shortly everybody
[Music]
so
and we returned ready for the bullet
portion of what has been a stellar match
up
to evenly matched players sam savion and
alexis serrano
before the match even began dania we saw
that the predictions
it was as pretty much as close as it
gets fifty-five percent
odds in sevien's favor forty-five
percent for
sarana dania we're in the bullet now
what do you think
indeed and the smarter chess prediction
has has been the case
very often it has been right on the
money and well it predicts a very close
a bullet segment i think that's
to be expected now we've seen in in the
previous we've seen some close matches
decided by the bullet but
we've seen a lot of cases where one
player basically just runs away with it
in the first couple of games
um i dare say i don't think that's going
to happen here i mean
these players have been so close and the
games have been so tightly contested i
don't see a reason why
one player should run away with it but
obviously you'd never know what do you
think
yeah it's tough to say with these two
competitors because
they've been evenly matched throughout
sarah not had a lead
seven came back just now so seven
probably is feeling good about himself
at least relative to what he was feeling
a little while ago
and in bullet especially with the
increment that makes all the difference
and serrano has been faster
but sevien has proven mighty in the last
bunch look at their ratings by the way
they're about the same
yeah and uh we'll see i mean those
benoni games
uh it's important for sardot to to make
sure they don't get under his skin
uh that he sort of resets and we do have
uh another night off here
which of course is right in alexis
wheelhouse but
probably sam as has been the case has
prepared certain openings specifically
for the bullet
and watch over bishop f3 isn't it just
wait a second no no this is 97 queen d5
check
uh there has been probably there's like
a queen trap there i mean there's
definitely alexi knows this
um you sure buddy
[Music]
yes i mean these are like known tactics
when you can't take on e4 because of the
light squares and
yeah shannon hasn't really moved from
his stance
but he's not only that this reminds me
of an
i'll get moderate video and of course
best wishes to to agamatter who
it appears that that his heart surgery
went well so prayers and and support
to to him but there was a funny video he
shared in one of his games where he
blundered a rook in exactly this fashion
and he pulled this stunt where he he was
pretending that he had something up his
sleeve uh but in reality he wanted to
resign and his opponent believed him but
here
there was enough just nothing at all no
this is a
clean extra rook for sevien and as you
said we wish antonio our very best and
hope that he has a
smooth recovery hello everyone let's
wish him the best
and uh hopefully he'll be back making
videos soon but for now
if you're a alexis serrano fan you
better hope that he's going to rebound
fast because there's not that much time
left 28 minutes all of it's going to be
bullet
and look at this we have the budapest
from sevien
i was going to make a pond with
antonio's last name
rad i was going to say it was a radical
development
but oh yeah that is a blow right there
in the early going as
budapest indeed that is a bullet opening
if i've ever seen now it's not actually
robert objectively it's not that bad
like it's at best i think white gets a
slight advantage which he has done
yeah you're right though because black
has the typical uh
access to the a file the bishop on b7
looks very good there's no d-pawn to go
d5 and shut down that bishop from b7
but for now i would say that white is
slightly better but black
is hanging there just fine indeed and uh
well c5
c5 exactly trying to chip away
no i think it should be in the realm of
a draw but these these positions are so
hard to play with the bullet but
look at the times they both have a
minute remaining essentially
what about 94 yeah just try to bail out
a nice e3 oh
nice yeah i'm also trying to take on g3
like everything is sort of hanging in
white's position even if you win a pawn
your pawn structure will be shattered so
knight e4 i'm looking at c takes d6
knight takes g3 here and you have to
take back with the fball
and he's taking his time with he has
left himself a good amount of time to
calculate he knows that if indeed this
is a draw
he's going to be able to survive but
he's got to move relatively fast
i mean with 10 seconds that's going to
be quite hard
yes okay he doesn't take on c5 like
about it i don't know
now he's definitely it should be still a
draw but okay i mean i think here
the realistic practical chances are
higher
okay oh and now with the double pawns
the c5 pawn
is it a strength is it a liability i
don't like what sarna just did there
because those pawns and i mentioned this
yesterday can actually be an
asset i know it sounds ridiculous that
even if black trades bishops it gives up
c5
that is almost impossible to win because
those pawns act kind of like a sponge
they soft up any attempts that white may
have at pushing his own pawns if that
makes sense
not to say that he's going to give up
he's not even going to give up c5 easily
i thought there's no king a4 there but
he didn't want to get his king cut off
that's a nice idea look at f4 rook at 5
as possible you play e4 and g4 and bring
the rook into f5
right and that's not to say winning
attempts are not possible with those
pawns but
it's not like completely winning for
white it's what i'm saying and this rook
can
go back and forth along the back rank
here putting pressure on g2 protecting
ponzi 5 here goes rook to g8
rookie 5
oh that's also looking good so he gives
the rookie four off from the trade
field agree accuracy by sarah not just
not allowing any of these attempts
i mean this is a very creative defensive
it's what you said even if you lose the
c
pawn this is still looking like a
theoretically drawn
alex alex your malinsky taught me this
in a lesson i had with him years and
years ago and i never forgot this he's
like
those pawns they can be the greatest
defensive asset
in a three-on-four end game he didn't
say it exactly like that
every russian school boy goes that
supports that looks the ugliest
in fact supposed
[Laughter]
and these pawns are doing just that you
know it's funny
how does white even win this game king
of five f4 somehow you know what you're
doing
you play the the classic bullet rook b5
or kc3 or k3
they try to make the rook and get onto
but that's where the increment
eliminates
this kind of plane but this is not a
serious attempt i mean he's doing what
he can of course as he should
but there's no way to make progress and
what i mean you can see here very
clearly how the pawns
exactly they're like spikes burying that
vampire
although if you were anton smyrnov you
would have really traumatic
recollections of this position because
he was up upon
and he lost on time against nihal sarin
yesterday but this is just
easy for black to hold you keep your
rook behind the pawns if
a pawn's ever traded then it just
there's no winning chances
we've been there before right with the
brook and f5 so king h6 i don't know
about i guess rook f3
whoa now he might have screwed this up
that's possible because you're trained
rookie
keep your rook behind the pawn you
should not have gone to h6
i'm with you that looks really bad
actually yes now wait a second wait a
second
for sure back to wait 7.3 seconds
there's rookie for some yeah seven it's
winning which is unbelievable
oh my gosh unbelievable we've seen this
one several times
don't play e6 rook g2 is good the king
is cut off you're gonna push your pawn
and then
it's just an easy lucina well you don't
even need the lasagna position
how how did this happen he had
everything under control
it's just what it shows is that in
working there's always going to be that
one attempt and here it is indeed the
classic lucena position you build a
bridge
and serrano probably learned this before
he
learned how to walk
here's the bridge he makes it he
promotes the pawn and that is why we saw
resignation
we have a tied match once again we do
and that was incredible i mean he found
he squeezed the life out of the position
found what he needed to find and that
critical mistake thinking that the game
is already over
what whoa
what did you see what just happened
there no i wasn't i wasn't looking
yeah look at that that was a jaba london
and sevien played 92 and then knight
back to g1 around to f3
what is that typical at all no i mean i
not saying an authority on the subject
even though i've played the java wonder
for you for years i've never seen that
before
it makes some sense i mean the thing
with the java is it's not like in these
positions every tempo
is crucial right that's true because
the position remains closed for a bit
and so there's no like quick attack or
anything of the swords
right now better white is definitely
better
you control the c file you also have a
pawn majority on the queen side over
here
and black's pawns don't get to mobilize
very easily you can't push e5 without
between d5
you push d4 i take you you're left with
double isolated pawns
okay this is a good explanation
maybe defense okay but this is just
looking terrible i mean look at the
crunch that we saw a game like this
a little bit earlier i think it was
sevien who was also the one dominating
that queen side
we see something similar here it's not
about winning a particular pawn
it's just black's position as a whole
that is not really holding together
although i like what sarna is doing
trying to trade as many pieces as
possible intercepting
the c file this is serious progress now
in the defensive end
oh yeah because now black's funds can
actually push e5 d4 and
whose pawns are better play e5
king f7 latch is much better now it
shows you in the bullet things can turn
around in the snap of a finger you miss
one opportunity to make progress
boom table's turn
and all right so here the bishop on c4
is just better than the counterpart on
d1 the bishop one g3 stuck to the
defense of this pawn h4
black with plenty of time hitting now
the b4 pawn
okay so is that a i guess you have
enough to hold the balance there
well it depends there's a lot of
tactical ideas in this specific queen h7
though because 557 is between f5
indeed indeed he's got to go queen c8 i
think right because if you get your
queen trapped over here and then the
black
queen could trade it off that looks like
a losing attempt rather than winning his
abs
oh wait no he's doing it but queen f8
sees something and then there's queen
champion
maybe g4 at the end but there's just
queen g8
takes and takes and takes i guess the
pawn is hanging there
i do agree with you though e5 or a5 can
be considered in some positions to fix
that font on a4
but quinje is the only move because if
you take on g4 threats of bishop takes
e6 with check
dislodging the king from the defense of
anything on g7 exactly no you have to do
it i don't know why he's taking so long
um if he doesn't do it he's just
probably gonna get in huge trouble
i yeah i just failed to see what else
there is and now
we see this end game or why does the
outside passer but
as you correctly pointed out robert that
pawn mass is
serious longer as material it really is
d3 bishop a2 bishop b1 bishop c2 that's
a god
long way to go but that's a possibility
but also look at the pawn on a6
you point these things out bishop g4
bishop ca that might create all of a
sudden very unpleasant
uh uh circumstances for black okay
to b3 bishop g8 would help the pawn push
but you have to watch out for the d-pawn
uh-oh who's bonus faster king g5 mg5 oh
no and now white f4 check probably he
has to play no but there was amphison
and like oh sarah
bishop h5 wrong color pawn
wrong pawn it's a draw wrong
you just keep the king there you don't
get the king out
amazing yeah this is the draw and
we should remind everybody as this game
was drawn the match is still
level at this point that if at the end
of this bullet portion it is a tie we
will have
an additional four one minute plus one
second increment games to try to break
the tie
and if that little mini match is tied we
get to armageddon
where white block five minutes black
will have three minutes
and black gets draw odds a distinct
possibility robert but
we haven't seen a match this close we've
seen close matches this is
literally down to the wire oh yeah what
a save that was from both players it
looked like uh sarana was taking the
advantage and then all of a sudden
seven had some chances and then seven
realized okay the wrong caller
uh with the coin oh knight d5 sorry
sorry interrupts you no no you're good
interrupt there's tactics on the board
and
now uh savings up a pawn in e4
this is not winning of course but here
c6 has to be prepared quickly he has to
get
the center open move the rook a6 and c6
sarah is doing a great job here limiting
that potential you might laugh donya i
think practically it's easier for white
to play no i would be
frightened completely agree because i
think he had that one opportunity he has
to prevent i
i like bishop c6 though but look at him
trying to prevent it a4 the knight can
come to c5 if you're not getting it
you have to be careful about that right
so bishop
so so we're not showing indications that
he's going to attack also on the king
side potentially with g4
that's a good point and that could
backfire because it may weaken your own
king
but for now you can put his queen on c6
oh but then
where's that queen going uh oh oh my
gosh
but then okay seven yeah the you know
rookie seven after rookie eight and what
okay
knight c5 i mean that's not the end of
the movie takes you back to get the
queen out queen i'm sick i don't think
this is that bad though just rook c7
what are you gonna do
knight queen f6 now yeah rook c7 is
where i actually
have some skits counter play because
queen takes b6 and i have before yeah
i don't know man i mean i mark my words
see i've already told you this once
black is going to get serious
counterplay i'm not going to say he's
going to win
okay this is not going to be obvious
there we go ooh g5 i like that move a
lot queen c6
hitting the rook on all right rookie
can i play just rookie i didn't like
giving the queen access here
now f5 f5 is another option
oh you're right f5 now because i wonder
knight before
fork drop stage g3
oh my gosh did you mark my words i am i
marked them down i am
now living them i'm seeing what's
happening here b7
okay because queen a7 there's no threat
b7 came to play the queen is hanging on
b7 it's still possible to blunder we
know how resilient
is there is there kind of a draw with
queen d7 queen g4 no the king just sits
on h
five maybe oh yeah yeah but then i have
queen h5 like do you actually get out
yeah yeah no i agree now he's going to
c6 he's trying to create connected
passers this is
27 grady 7 the rook's hanging but
rook b8 and then king f8 so b7 if you
move your queen
so queen a7 is queen g4 queen c8 back
and forth between d6
queen e6 is also hanging with e5 to fall
broke alexis
knight f193 can i bring my knight in or
do i give you additional ideas but does
that allow
checks that's what i'm worried about oh
my gosh so much is happening queen seven
you go free g5 also is a possibility
okay but now g1 is possible king c2 i
guess watch out for queen c8 so
wait quincy it's a queen knight c4 who's
winning there
take something 366. yeah knight c4 is
coming
okay but i thought maybe you could take
him going x4 but he wants to do it
anyway queen e7
it's a repetition queen c7 27 keep the
rook under attack
queen i would take and go knight c4 oh
my gosh taking knight c4 you win the d6
pawn by four if that's not over because
black has the h fun who is winning there
there might be a repetition another draw
king moves i suggest king moves
so he plays h4 knight c4 h3 the king and
then the queen comes to g5 i think black
sacrifices on b8 and promotes
oh man so king f1 h2 he doesn't
so 66 took with the queen and now the
knight comes in and replaces the queen
but then h2 wait take any five oh you
talk about that takes b7
could you do an h2 queen about who's
winning i think the blacks twins you're
getting
the check game queen with check
unbelievable
wins the night stops the pawn that's
unreal everything worked out perfectly
and if you are sarnat you resign
stop playing this game resign there he
goes he does
he's frustrated but 15 minutes left on
the match clock plenty of time it's a
one-point game but this is where you
have to stop the bleeding if you're
alexi
yes and well where's the next game
where's the next game
they gotta they gotta reaction it's not
15 minutes a bullet it's 30.
yeah i don't know what just happened but
it's like 10 seconds came off i think
the server might have what my
no okay no it's not oh no it might be
because on my end it's glitching a
little bit
no i but i see now all of a sudden sarna
has full uh phil and
it's sevien who asked me but i think
that was
both players temporarily yeah i see it
right now both players are
connections are struggling there indeed
indeed
something seems now's our own eyes back
but he's got 37 he's got to move
um i'm going to ask for confirmation
just to see what's happening
and it looks like uh uh
team is dealing with behind the scenes
seeing what's going on with the players
uh we will await their word but right
now i mean dania this
has been as close of matches you could
ask for
and the game was just cancelled okay so
the players
uh will restart this and i'm sure the
time will be added back to the match
clock
and uh that way it's all fair so it
seems like it was a
mutual problem not just one player maybe
it was a
quick little sort of reboot but
hopefully we get the games going
very shortly here and players still
seated getting ready for
the next game indeed indeed and uh yeah
this happens but robert i need to catch
my breath
there's some of my friends watching the
match texted me about this game that was
crazy
and yeah i mean this this has been crazy
it looks like that players are
in communication with the team who's
doing such a great job behind the scenes
making sure that everything's okay and
we do have liftoff so that was a very
interesting
quick fix thank you um mira
jake pick everybody who's helping out
thank you so much for that
and we do have the next game everything
seems to be right
and we have a fiance so a slower
approach from sevien
from an opening standpoint but he does
have a one game lead indeed and i also
have to add my shout out
such a professional job always done by
the people behind the scenes we'll thank
them properly at the end but
uh this would all not be possible
without them
okay so yeah i like white's position
here because of the c5 square there is a
lack of equivalency between
the c5 score on the one hand but the c4
square is not accessible obviously
because white is upon on b3 i think
white is a slight pull
but it's not that significant right
because 93 is play you do not want to
allow a trade with a side that's
slightly less space in this case it's
black
with a bit less space and you want to
somehow get your c3 knight to c5
so do not play b4 if you're black that'd
just well now you might play b4 whoa
got to watch out but i think that giving
the a4 then c5 square is
not advisable so on the other hand black
has more space
this is this position
that's the thing and look at that
diagonal the bishop has left the long
diagonal
so black has to record with that this
should be five
so bishop b5 you still can't take next
the rook is hanging though it's
close and he plays knight look at that
he's like you can't take me the knight
on f6 is always
hanging over here knight f4 to d3
reinforce that pony
he takes on d7 that bit of a bailout no
knight d3
but why do you have to take on d7 can
you just bring the knight to d3 first
right keep the temperature now he's
reorienting himself toward the queen's
head look at the c file though it isn't
under white's control because rook dixie
can be met with queen 62 so he's
increasing the pressure adding the
tabasco sauce but is it enough
uh okay he's bringing the bishop in
watch out for a sack on e6 at the right
moment
so that's why sauron brings the bishop
to d6 another idea is to play at some
point before all of these central breaks
but will they make them happen or will
white over extend himself he can take on
f4
and take on id you can and i'm looking
at rook c5 for white at some point not
now of course because the
knight is hanging but you can sacrifice
look at the bishop on h3 watch out shoot
you cannot play knight d3 oh my gosh
it's trapped
and you can't play that same reason how
what do you do do you take on e6 do you
bite the bullet
he does take any six which is just pawn
takes six is lost no of course take on
c1 play queen eighty-eight queen
eight and the queen e4 here five hangs
he did too much tabasco sauce
and the bishop's still trapped if it
went over to uh h3
oh it ain't over till it's over g4
though carving out those light squares
yeah there's queens okay for anyway the
c7 square is covered
queen f5 threatening queen of three you
go knight g4 he plays knight d5 you get
the blockade trade queens and win the
game here
huge huge win uh robert
and one felt that perhaps you released
the tattoo too early i felt like seven
had that chance with his knight on c5
you called it
i think he went in the wrong direction
there it is still a tight match with 11
minutes to go we got a bangkok give it
another change
i know savion likes this opening he's
been playing it since he was very young
he does indeed it's upon sacrifice but
you get such good piece play
and in bullet in particular that is good
for the side that has the easier plan
so the pawn has been lost or sacrificed
i should say and
uh there are just under 11 minutes on
the match like whoa knight g5
giving up the e6 pawn now knight c7
played to defend that square is more
important to
not allow the knight in taking this
bishop off the board indeed
and um i this these positions are
as crazy as it gets the vanco has become
a little bit less popular
recently but that does not mean it's not
a good bullet weapon but i it
does not seem like a good bullet weapon
right now look at what's happening to
savion's position i mean look at this
bishop on seed
26 mate was a threat so how many
did you you don't have a pawn for the
exchanges looking into the top of the
center
you're the center but you don't actually
have material for the exchange rights
and these are not saying ladies and
gentlemen
passport star of the show red carpet
unrolled a6 coming this is looking very
bad
it certainly is and you know now you can
play queen into b5 but now you can't
because the pawn came to c4
but rook a4 hits the c four pawn behind
it is the d4 point both of them are weak
and if you ever play rook c8 well thank
you for removing your rook from the path
of my pawn
indeed d3 queen g4 unsustainable is the
pawn motion for black because he just
doesn't have enough resources to hold
everything together asics
convincing confidence and again the
opening
uh prowess of not coming into play here
even though it's the bullet
that extra edge robert in knowing the
opening knowing the theory now here
still some hurdles to cross that a4 rook
is hanging and d1 is going to be hanging
out for that
that's true because i want to play 26
check but i need to also maybe play rook
d1 to a1 i'm going to bring rook a to a1
tough question do you want to double
your rooks behind the pawn he does so he
can play a7 a8
and a7 yeah okay six rook a6 queen e6
check coming
yeah he's holding him down here and if
you trade queens you're just completely
lost but then d2 i would argue that's
not so simple i wouldn't be able to six
yet i would go
yeah so centralization hitting the d5
pawn you can also play rook a5 to win d5
queen e4 creates a bit of a pawn diamond
there now you play slowly g3 or h3 i
would just throw that throw that in
there so you don't have to worry
but bishop g7 needs to be reckoned with
as well he does do this because you
pretend this queen eve oh
hangs the plane i'm trying to get my
queen of b8 but i
can't even have f4 though your idea is
absolutely right yes so bishop g7 i move
my queen away bishop takes b2 you sack
the other rookie you bank on your pawns
that doesn't work though
no because my queen on beat also takes
b2 back nice he doesn't play queen b6 is
even better can be seven
yes queen b7 rook bc two and you come
around for the pawns
he's gotta resign and start the next
game eight minutes same same logic as
the previous game
rook d6 wins oh rook d6 is so nice
removing the guard of this rook on eight
and then you're getting your queen
amazing again here by seven and now the
ball passed back into sam's court he's
trying
everything he can resigns eight minutes
on the clock this is another pivotal
game robert as the lead
shifts to alexis sarina and sam actually
seems very
calm right now maybe he's both
convincing himself to be calm but
nerves must be real someone has to up a
game right now we have no ceiling this
is going to get sharp
so lines like this the queen can often
come to g3 but not so fast because
knight h5 would hit the queen on g3 and
pawn f4
f5 now this could backfire if black gets
d5 and this is an old idea that has been
around a long time
now if white can play bishop g5 takes f6
and plan tonight on d5 a couple of
classical games have gone this way
things are very unpleasant to sir not
understandably but still
look at that d5 square that is how the
battle is going to be decided oh my god
like what sam is doing queen g3 coming
g5 the d4 pawns hanging as well
whoa but bishop takes a 5. oh bishop f5
was missed
opportunity so f6 get rid of that pawn
don't hang on anymore bishop cc again
bishop f5 but there's the e5 pawn
still though i would do it again but d4
was hanging
earlier as well because the queen has
not been defended now look at the
positional sack he's going to plant a
rook on him for a blockading rook now
he's going to redirect his attention to
the attack i don't see what saranac can
do here
to throw water onto the fire right
because you put g6 in comes h5
h5 anyway look at how quickly seven is
playing this
knight h4 knight five bring that knight
tightening the screws
chiseling his way inside the paint
knight f5 and g6 even
he takes first because knight five
knight h6 check or queen f3 hitting up
seven this is crushing
absolutely crushing and what a
performance here by sebby and tying the
match it seems but let's not jinx him
sorry not can generate chances in any
position and that was a
must by sevien was blocking the light
squares he gave him a pawn
but said the control is good enough ooh
f7 is under attack queen f3 or g6 as
you're saying
look good he plays g6 i have some slight
concern if this rook on e7 you can come
to g7 or h
completely echoed yeah agreed but i
think it's a case where all roads lead
to rome
yeah knight f7 check always available oh
my gosh and you take an h7 with check
rook h4 rookie chain mate it's just very
forcing sequence no
you did if you play rook g7 knight of
seven check knife sound still just
throw that pony in there mm-hmm g takes
and then rook g4 rook g8 thank you
yeah gamer gp4 it's made for queen h6 is
a symbolic check
okay okay well you can't i'm not sure
about this one
rookie five yeah i think you're pretty
sure now aren't you
yeah i'm pretty sure i was always sure
you have a problem being sure
do we need to replace the commentator
here in the last five minutes
we might because it's just this is
really riling me up
yeah it seems that we have quite the
argument here i mean this is ridiculous
and if you're seven you tie the match up
if you are
sarina you're looking at the match clock
probably not right now because you're in
the middle of a pretty
good no he's looking he's old he's not
even looking at the position but i'm
looking at it so
five minutes remaining and if you're
sarina
like this is going back and forth at
this point how are you feeling after a
loss
it's like you know it reminds me of and
i've made some comparisons to basketball
but you know that situation when you go
for what's called a two-for-one
30 seconds left in the game and the
match is how you throw up a shot
so that you will have at least another
one guaranteed
now this is actually getting a little
bit interesting here
i think the eight pawn is too fast yeah
five and one oh wait go can use three
first
one nice move because that's pissing you
do not want to allow rook check
so then the punch goes a6 rook takes d6
is the threat with the 8466
don't play a7 which is still winning 66.
so now there are at least i think two
more games guaranteed right
how does sarna play this i don't think
he plays it he plays it
like a regular game he's not trying to
play particularly fast but
robert we've seen these players they
have just naturally played very very
fast
and very confidently which is crazy and
i just
love this image they're going back and
forth as you see with the dancing heads
and this this line with a c7 pawn is
captured once again
black and this is sam sebian gets the
activity for the material
and there is a game i still always
forget was it
nakamura versus caruana it might have
been carlson i don't remember who
i think all of them have played this
yeah it just it's a pawn sacrifice where
you take on f1 the king has to take and
then you can bring your rooks to the c
files
i think i'm more nervous than the
players or my heart is beating right now
i feel like i'm
entering a final exam in college or
something this is this is what we came
here for
three wait a second that rook might be
trapped there's rook to be five back so
you guys
okay so this is a little bit raj now
who's better in this situation i like
the knight i like white central control
but i don't think the advantage is
particularly significant if it exists at
all
well this this pawn a3 was hanging it
was rook a1 rook takes a7 so just
returning uh that pawn so that's why he
didn't do it and this position is
definitely better for white you have a
knight and a light square can't be
attacked before
d5 some type of ideas you have a5 i
think i just heard you say that
and this is just favorable for sauron
for sure you can push and look at the
time speed this is hard to defend
he makes progress first he's got to
watch out
f5 is an idea no this is actually
looking really really bad for black i
didn't even realize the extent of it
over now but he kicks the rook away and
he's going to take on f5 and play g6 and
ah trade some pieces here he comes nice
good call he takes an e4 though
oh i didn't like that move because the
jeep cemented
oh gosh here comes the knights of the d5
square still b4 and bishop d6 how
exactly does white make frog you put the
bishop on e6 first more flexible
okay so i'm looking at an eventual rook
to g1 not yet doesn't do too much of
anything
but kd7 maybe then a rook g1 and then 95
threatens the f6 pawn because the g
dude okay okay so he's trying to open up
that ankle gearing himself up
he closes it back down but the c4 square
is weak and the knight can come there
because
he's pushing that pawn forward i would
say don't play a5 because the knight
would come right to c4 to attack it and
he's trying to get the eight
king c3 threat big threat rook b5 rugby
five that way bishop before check
and to win this bishop before he misses
it he's gotta go back and now bishop a5
that might be
a five i think you're holding i think
you're holding you are you are you are
and white's still better even there but
i think the black king just goes right
back to f8 and once it gets there it
protects g7 he goes
now pawn end game could be trouble
because e5 e60 is a protected password
he doesn't do it he shines away
afterwards he's six look at that move
he's trying to open the fifth rank for
the rook
over to h5 that's a good idea and now
it's time
to make take and kick through what do
you do
before checking it yeah yeah yeah go
back
and the one thing i'm curious about is
is there a time that rook g1 try to get
the g6 pawn
two okay you use the king to stop the
pawn the rook to attack but you can't
take on g6 just yet right because then
you played b2 so you have to do that for
f5 maybe you do something
there's one tempo you have you always
have king eight there you go three you
go to f7 to protect the pawn
very deep and you call the king c3 okay
bishop b4 and bishop c5 what a catch you
could actually still do it and go 96 at
the end but the rook is protected
right so king b3 bishop c5 check it back
king b2 looks like the only move he goes
king d3
so maybe net wasn't the only move but it
worries me to move away from that pawn
minute they're gonna have one more game
probably after this one
how will this game end they're shuffling
their pieces around this game might not
end for a minute actually so this
is gonna be our last game rook g2
hitting the g6 pawn
don't take it because b2 bishop before
check now king b3 how he takes oh
the g66 is gonna fall f5 play a five at
some point play f5 he's gonna watch the
clock two he's gotta resign if this gets
lost
yes he does he knows 38 seconds left oh
and now we'll fork on b7 is a threat the
rooks you want great move
okay seven bishop g3 at some point i
don't know when
um where are you six now this is a push
i would actually consider resigning this
i would consider it as well 25 seconds
left bishop g3 played knight of 70 goes
back to
four rook c three she keep challenging
he hasn't got to be aware of the clock
he's gotta resign it
and he's gotta resign it rook takes up
six it's another point if that's on five
there's twelve seconds left he doesn't
see the clock the rookie six assists a
drives us a win
and he's got one second he barely gets
resigned he's got to resign inside he's
got himself
beside he didn't he didn't he resigned
he gets one more game
with two seconds oh my gosh
oh my god i've never been so happy to
see somebody resign in my life
in a game that's not my own so we have
the sicilian once again it was
uh seven who played a great game pushes
the pawn to f5 same exact variation
sarnath thinks it plays d5 but is that
good take on d3 this time is it good
because their e5 pawn is hanging as well
so this is a i think ed is is a move
here and then the e5
hangs but you get liquidation there he
has to win this game he's down by a
point this is the last one
okay so he the e51 is falling and then
when the e5 falls the bishop 105 is
under attack so knight takes e5
wait why isn't this just an extra pawn
it is bishop f4 but
okay the pawns are weak bishop d6 is an
idea but there's a big initiative on top
of the pawn
white has to keep this initiative stoked
d4 to keep the knight supported what
will he do here d4 looks good
okay i was thinking just taking on g6
but he wants to keep that knight in the
center make sense bishop can't move
because he needs to protect the f6
knight
and queen d6 played do i take on g6 c4
do i take him fill the square with my
queen on e5 like can i replace it
in that maybe you do yeah nice using 3d5
i quite like that but knight 65 at the
end there's no
no but there's 97 to 4. oh i had that
covered you know you've been great with
the tags today but
every now and then i got this the knight
is pinned f7 is falling
okay this is very hard to play robert
with the black piece but look at the
time 15 seconds extra for starting up
that could
make its presence felt yeah and i'm
going to give you
that oh knight g4 takes it but just
taking
this is the last game he knows that he's
trying to figure this out rookie one
okay i like that
you didn't have to rush back to e5 and
that way the bishop cannot get to f6
i like to move the knights here are
there's so many outposts the c6 were
created a3 stopping before
oh now knight's coming to c6 is not
because bishop f6 knight c6
there we go and they're not holding it
together can you choose to trade rooks
on e8 and then play rookie one i don't
see a way to make progress yeah i think
you have to do they have to
fight for the e file that's what he does
he wants to double
yeah so what's happening here hmm
okay he does double he gets the e5 but
sarna creates that hole for the king on
h7
but there's a 97 at some point not now
because rook to e8 but that's what the
king went to h7
and here we look at the position white
is much better here he is
h3 prudent but he creates a weakness on
g3 there is a downside to it oh he
trades the bishop system that's
important
that's important this he's making
progress so he's protecting the d5 pawn
with look at five but you don't even
need to because there's no way to double
on the pawn the knight c6 is too
powerful
i like this move rook f3 you can play g4
king g2 if you want or g3 kg2
yeah so okay what now queen if i love
that move
off for the queen's raid okay he doesn't
want to give the
e8 good move keeping control of the
files 95 shifting it around f7 under
pressure knight g4 is an idea here rook
c3 coming to c6 to the right spots
rook c5 good move look at the protected
rookie eight by starting out rookie
eight rook c6
so rookie six anyway because you're
gaining ground 25 is also very good
looks good trade the rise oh i thought
you'd trade the rooks there
now this is dangerous the bishop h4
something like that i think white's king
is weak he has to give another king
knight back to e5
okay queen of four i don't like the
retreat but maybe he felt he was
necessary or not
five seconds oh my gosh this is tough
quincy seven no doesn't attack anything
rook c7 there's no threat oh that's such
an important one
it's a huge blow bishop takes d4
straight queens ah it doesn't look good
for him
no it's still i think he's maintaining
some pressure 26 now of course
okay but look at that at five squared is
that significant taking c4 though i
don't see it happening
no because when you take nd4 the rook
takes with check four but the knight can
wherever there is tonight there are
chances but
are not defending so well here you need
the knight to come to f5 right somehow
he brings his knight to h2 knight g4
bishop b2 and then
jumping to e3 out of five scores we got
five check though f5 check
oh he can't take it because rookie six
and so on this is a huge blow this is
looking
very tough now for seven he needs to win
this game and how is he going to win
this does now he's going back to that
one only by a four rookie one is
possible at some point actually there's
nowhere to go yeah so rookie one looks
very good
93 oh king c3 trying to trap the knight
but back to
oh look at that he realized the king on
the c file no longer the rook
on say it hits the c one square he's
trying desperately knight of four check
don't fall for that though knight d4
rook c6 okay he run rook f6 so he saw
that you got to keep trying here if
you're seven you got to keep the knight
preserve then f4 f4 and f3 and you're
just gonna force a trade here
knight f4 you were looking at rook j
from g6 but bishop
very important that's basically it this
is it
that's it you've got to try something
like rook
there's just no way to lose this if
security there is no winner loses yeah
you don't want to too much time
play for k6 you know just hope for the
pre-move mm-hmm no you have to try that
but
yeah it's got to take on b3 but but no
it's over
g2 and this is
look at him pumped up as he should be
the clutch game with black and what an
effort by sevi an amazing job and
the presence of mind to resign i know
this sounds ridiculous and then a
fantastic effort
and it came down right to the why what a
match
what the match there are so many
brilliant moves over the board but the
resignation was maybe the
most of all realizing it with just two
seconds in the clock but
all credit to alexis serena for winning
this match
it was so back and forth nerves must
have been just like
overwhelming and yet he did keep his
composure in the end he wins the match
thirteen nine and eleven half we're
going to take a short
technological recess because when we
come back we will be joined by the
players for a post-match interview
i am so looking forward to hearing their
thoughts because
there's just so many jitters we'll be
right back everybody stay tuned
[Music]
and after an exhilarating finish we are
joined by the players
first and foremost alexa huge
congratulations i have to ask you
how nervous were you down the stretch of
the match
okay thank you very much it was really
nervous much
because i think i played this much
really
good but sometimes and
i i was really good preparing in the
opening
and then i know something happened
in the time travels so and some
come back and in the bullet i just
think that i am big outsider
so i'm really happy how
happens so i don't know
well uh congratulations alexa and sam
that was a fantastic match
by you so many amazing games and
you know this may sound weird but we
were actually impressed with the
presence of mind you had in the
penultimate game
resigning it just as the clock expired
giving yourself one more game
were you sort of aware of that
specifically and
on a more general note um what are your
thoughts about the match sort of what do
you feel went well
what do you feel didn't go as well uh
for the first question
i saw there was eight minutes left and
there are two games left and
uh i felt they have to resign as fast as
possible
and for the match i mean he said he was
very well prepared
especially in this nimzo e4 line he had
an idea in almost every game
um yeah basically what went wrong was in
the bullet
that binko game i just lost really
quickly and that was
that probably was the reason yeah that
definitely makes sense and you know you
obviously had a good shot even in the
final game but in bullet anything can
happen
uh well alexa it seemed like earlier in
the
match things were starting to go your
way you're gaining some confidence but
then
you know the match kept getting even
when you had a lead it then went to even
so
how did you keep your composure and
manage your way through that because
nerves and just the tension of winning
and losing
it must get to you a little bit right
yes okay it's really hard when you lost
your leading
so i just i just play the game
sometimes i tilt it and but
but i think i play
more
i i was wasn't so tilted i
i missed i
miscalculate not too much and i think so
and this was important that even if
after
loses i miscalculate not
some remaining beams yeah
well uh alexi before we we let uh you go
both of you go for it for a deserved
rest you're playing uh
jeffrey zhang on sunday i'm sure you're
very well familiar with jeffrey uh do
you have any thoughts on
on jeffrey and how you might approach
that coming oncoming match
okay in this tournament jeffrey is
the most higher rated player and
much more famous than others so
i think that his favorite of the
tournament
i don't know what to do with him in the
next match so
i try to try to play but
i think his big favorite
wow but here but here
he won matches not so easily
so maybe so everyone had
chances against him it's true and you're
a very strong player obviously and the
modesty is
certainly noticed but uh alexa
congratulations to you and sam
sorry that the match didn't go your way
and hope to see you maybe in the
super swiss blitz event tomorrow and
throughout the weekend but uh
you know you did put up such a great
showing and it made for a very fun match
well done both of you
and thanks to uh both of our players for
what was i mean
honestly one of the absolute most fun
matches i've ever covered
the resignation with two seconds on the
match clock
just prolonging it giving it another
game and as we see alexis serrano moves
into the semifinals
he's so humble donya you just heard him
there he's like
jeffrey's more famous he's well known
he's the big favorite but
you know maybe i have some chances some
i think he has plenty of trouble
i mean i love that about all of these
players is how humble they are they let
their moves do the talking and uh
they put such effort into each and every
match and definitely i think alexi
he definitely has a chance he he just
played some amazing chess we'll go back
through the games i'm sure he'll analyze
them he'll prepare
we know about his opening preparation
now that is going to be a scintillating
match but not to downplay the effort of
course of sam sevien who
put on a fantastic display and it
literally came down
literally came down to the last second
it really did and for sam while his jscc
run comes to conclusion he has a chance
to make the
speeches championship that is a huge
goal for all these players
and the tournament begins tomorrow with
the speedchest
super swiss have an opportunity to make
his way
into the big sec where you can play the
likes of hikaru nakamura
and easy win fellow superstar grand
masters i'm sure wesley
all of them will make their presence
very much felt in the
speed chess championship but for now
donia we have
four semi-finalists jeffrey zhang takes
on alexis serrano
on the other side of the bracket we will
have nihal sarin taking on hike marti
rosian
it's just so much fun is it not it's
every match
the time just flies by these games each
and every one of them
amazing action so close so much tactics
so much just tension and so much effort
so much preparation we've got all of the
ingredients of one amazing match after
another
and uh these matches are good in and of
themselves
but you know what makes them better for
me commentating with
the likes of grand master robert hess so
it really always is
a huge pleasure to cover these matches
with you as well as
to cover them alongside thousands of
fans across various platforms
you know absolutely and we often joke at
each other's expense
but honestly the hours flew by today i'm
looking at
the clock on my computer here i'm like
whoa
already we've been doing this for almost
four hours now
but it's such a joy and matches like
that i mean we talked yesterday the
match-up
between uh nihal tsar and anthon smirnov
that was great fun
this one felt even more exhilarating
just because it was down to the wire
it wasn't clear who was going to win the
match until literally the very last game
so i mean what what a pleasure what a
joy it is
we're spoiled honestly we really are
every match opportunity
exceeds the preview i mean every single
match is is a story is a narrative
it's so much fun but unfortunately this
one comes to an end
on the bright side we have of course a
very big tournament over the weekend and
we have
two more semi-finals robert that are
bound to be
as exciting as it gets they certainly
will
so on that note you've done a great job
thanking everyone
but i want to reiterate your thanks and
just really give a big shout out to all
of our viewers
who continue to make this such a
successful run in the junior speeches
championship
for now the action does come to a close
we will come back very shortly with
the semi-finals and ultimately to
determine the champion
tomorrow will be the super swiss part of
the speed chess championship
qualification process
but it's time for us to say goodbye this
was the junior speeches championship
quarterfinals
brought to you by chess.com and
chesskid.com
until next time everybody
[Music]
you